hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast i am brett weinstein your host
and i have the privilege of sitting with
sam harris cognitive neuroscientist and
philosopher I actually feel like
although he needs no introduction there
is a thing that I wish showed up in his
bio but I'm having trouble figuring out
how to phrase something like Sam is an
important node in our collective
conscious architecture not everybody
agrees with Sam but he thinks matters
I'll take it and I'll take it that's
right
awesome yeah I'm not sure I can apply it
to myself but I will take it from you
this that's great
I don't see why I should apply any less
to you than anybody else all right so
thank you for doing this Sam I really
appreciate your willingness to engage
arguments that I know must feel like
people run you through all the time and
at some level maybe they should just
read your books to find out what the
answers to the questions that they would
pose to you are and I should say that in
preparation for today I have done a fair
amount of reading of your material just
to refresh my memory as to what you
believe and to figure out whether or not
there is indeed a gap worth discussing
sure yeah well I I find that certainly
for some of these topics conversation is
much more flexible than just volleys of
prose right so so email or blog post or
article or book it's just it's too rigid
because you really you can't interact
with anyone's real-time response to to
what you've written there so it's people
just bounce off the arguments more often
than not so you know I'm happy to talk
about it well there's that I also think
that the hidden magic of human nature
actually involves active discussion
about what we disagree over and that we
have learned to think in a very
different way because school trains us
to function differently but that in
essence a podcast discussion is the
resurrection of a very ancient and
vitally important human form something
that might once have taken place over a
campfire now takes place
somewhat more asynchronously and a lot
more people can listen in but anyway I
do think that this is in some ways the
return to to an earlier form and maybe
books were a temporary detour yeah yeah
living through the Golden Age of
conversation in some ways so it's I'm
happy to be doing it with you yeah or
maybe this is the beginning of that
Golden Age and we're discovering how to
do it you know one of the things that
frustrates me about the moment that we
live in is that we've settled on an
almost arbitrary mode of deciding what
conversation should happen and when they
should happen and that a little bit of
thinking about how formally this should
all go down might increase the extent to
which we we reach new objectives or even
things that we didn't know to pursue hmm
so let me say in reading I in
preparation for this I read free will I
read your book lying I read a good chunk
of the moral landscape and I read your
wife's book on consciousness oh nice so
that gave me some kind of insights and I
do have the sense that you are super
unusual in the way that you think
there's a way that your books almost
encyclopedic ly explore your own
thoughts on a topic so that in essence
you're leading the reader through every
path you've been down and where it ends
and so it's sort of like a status report
on all of those arguments and then
ultimately the book arrives at your
conclusion about what all these things
say together but this it raises a
question for me I worry about anybody
who's written the book including myself
I'm writing a book with Heather at the
moment and I have another one planned
and there's a question about once you've
written a book unless you've gotten it a
hundred percent right you are now in a
new predicament if it turns out that
something about what you've written is
what you thought at a moment but then it
turns out you end up somewhere new there
are there aren't great mechanisms for
updating and so I see a lot of people
who have written themselves into
and been unable to escape it hmm unless
you've written a book about the moral
evil of a line in which case you you're
anchored to that so I hope I'm honest
enough to declare I've realized I'm
wrong on any topic I've put into print
the topic that I think we're going to
touch free will is one where I'm it's
not a matter of sunk cost or being
identified with a position it's just a
the the topic is the the the geometry of
the topic both of our knowledge and what
seems to promise to be the frontier of
our ignorance seems unusually clear to
me right so it's not like they're
they're many topics where I'd be the
first to admit that whatever my opinion
is it's you know it's up against a just
a vast region of ignorance which is yet
to be illuminated free will is not
really one of those topics so I'm you
know I'm very I have very few reasons to
revisit my my published position here
but I'm happy to do it but it's just
it's one place where I'm you're gonna
yeah I'm either gonna seem unusually
incorrigible or or you know arrogantly
overconfident or something depending on
somebody's commitment to the opposing
view so well there's there's a question
of how you will seem to members of the
audience and you know audiences are
large so you'll see them every way to
some yeah yeah but to me you're not
gonna see in that way I know there are
zones where I've been so thoroughly over
a landscape that it's always possible
something new is going to arise but I've
I've chased every argument from every
side and so I'm not really expecting to
hear something new and I understand that
free will is a place where you feel like
that's the case now I'm hoping to drive
you into a headspace that opens
something on this topic and will vary
whether that actually happens I don't
know whether that would be positive or
negative from your perspective but can
we detour to your book lying for sure
sure so I listened to book lying
actually I listened it on the plane and
I in particular love to listen to books
where the author is reading it and in
fact you you read lying so you'd get to
hear it somebody there's some emotional
content in the cadences and things like
that and I wondered as I was listening
to your argument which I overwhelmingly
agree with and I find some analogy and
how you see this topic and how I see
this topic that I think is not common I
don't think we're in exactly the same
place but more similar place than
probably two people chosen at random
would be likely to find themselves but I
wondered if you wrote that book which
makes a very powerful argument that
almost none of the places that a human
being tends to see some sort of lying as
justified are actually justified if you
chase the full calculus of the
consequences of doing so and obviously
as you hinted at a couple of minutes ago
that having stated that out loud and
very clearly puts you in a kind of a
bind that you obviously either
inadvertently chose or chose knowingly
hmm and I was wondering was there any
part of you when you wrote that book
that was seeking to tie your own hands
no well let's just spell out what fine
do you think that is I imagine it's that
you think because I've been so public in
my admonishment around honesty that I I
can never lie in any circumstance
now because that I have so many people
watching to see whether I'm in you know
whether I'm likely to do that or
inclined to shade the truth is that what
you mean that I've basically set the bar
publicly and and and now I've got many
people they can potentially call me to
account that's the shallow end um I
would say in the deep end would be you
know in the book you explore things like
marital infidelity friend what you have
effectively done in writing that book is
increased the cost that would come to
you if you engaged in marital infidelity
and it came to light the degree to which
you would be viewed as hypocritical is
beyond what most people would face and
that presume you increases the
likelihood of it yeah no I'm not aware
of that as a motive that is a
consequence of it I mean it's a happy
consequence of it that I feel like the
the only way for me to really fail is to
is to not honor this deepest value right
and I'm happy for that kind of larger
expectation that I you know that I won't
you know betray that value and I'm happy
to have you know it's like you know the
perverse version of it is you know this
is this dates both of us but you know
when Gary Hart was campaigning and he
invited the press to you know just you
just follow me around you know and then
he was he was immediately caught having
an affair I think if you're someone who
really wants to adhere to a a path which
at least on this point seems fairly
straight and and clearly lit I love the
fact that people expect me to be honest
and and that I that I've advertised that
as widely as I as I can and that I would
be more hypocritical than most to be
dishonest yeah you know that that would
be and I think the the obverse of that
coin the fact that there is so little
consequence to public dishonesty in most
walks of life and the fact that we have
a president who is the I think even you
know most of his fans would admit lies
more than almost any public figure that
they can possibly be named you know in
any sense right now he'd be a hypocrite
I mean stand the fact that
it's you in many corners not considered
a bug but a feature and I think that's
just that's that's on that's probably at
the top of a very short list of worst
things about our public conversation at
this point you know I mean and it and
opens the door to all of the other toxic
stuff about our conversation I think
intellectual honesty is our only real
error correcting mechanism you know it
is that it is what safeguards human
rationality and it's the only thing that
promises that human conversation allows
us to explore you know what it grope
towards what is true in any kind of
reliable way and you know insofar as we
have that right in science that's one of
the very good things about science and
what's that's what makes it science and
not some other zone of you know human
fabrication and I think interpersonally
honesty is just as important so ya know
I'm happy to be on record in this way
yeah I I agree and I think actually it's
very wise because in some sense honesty
is not easy and that engineering some
sort of a paradigm in which it's
expected of you is on the one hand
limiting and has to be in some sense
costly but that net the cost is probably
well worth it for the benefit of you
know as you point out in your book not
having to for example track lives that
need to be tended yeah that's a huge
cause that people pay yeah and it's it's
just a one I when I think about it in
the context of my marriage or in in
relationship to my daughters knowing
that the other person isn't going to lie
to you is such a refuge right now that
the but again the flipside of this would
be that if you ever you know if I if I
ever lied to my wife and got caught it
would be an immense betrayal of a sort
that you know most other marriages might
not recognize right because because we
have
such primacy around the notion that
we're not going to lie to each other but
having you know put all our chips on
that it's it really is it really makes
the relationship a kind of refuge that I
really can't imagine the alternative to
yeah I agree with you and this raises a
couple of nearby points that I think are
maybe worth exploring one of them has to
do with your position what you describe
as an allergy to participating in
advertising hmm and I have exactly the
same aversion I can't say it exactly the
same level but at some very extreme
level and so obviously I'm now starting
a podcast and trying to figure out how
one Ds does that and it's not an
inexpensive process and there's a
question about the time that goes into
it and how you end up paying for it and
advertising is one obvious route but
yeah I can't help but think that there
is some hazard to one's credibility at
the very reason that an advertiser will
pay to put some product in you know to
have you speak as if you care about that
product mmm the very reason that they
wish to borrow your voice is that your
voice has a kind of credibility that is
eroded when you are involved in selling
items right yeah well maybe I should
should clarify that I don't think it
need be or at least there's their gray
areas here where it's probably not worth
worrying about the the ethical
implications because I think there are
people who can advertise credibly and in
fact it's so convergent with their brand
that it's what their audience wants from
them so I think of like my friend Tim
Ferriss who has a very successful
podcast it's ad sponsored but Tim's
thing is finding good stuff too
to use to do you know he's like a you
know he's mean he's got many things at
this point but we kind of core to his
brand is to be able to think about
himself as and what he does as as kind
of brand management I mean he's a
marketer he's a brilliant marketer and
there's just no problem with him finding
the next piece of fitness gear that he
thinks is amazing and telling his
audience this is amazing because that's
I mean yeah I'm his friend and a part of
his audience and I want to know what the
next piece of fitness gear is that he
wants to get behind right so yeah I'm
just not that kind of you know person in
the world so I agree and I you know I
don't know if I will ultimately have to
do advertising just as a practical
matter and I've certainly thought about
the border where the only things that I
would advertise would be things that I
actually like the product and that means
that's obviously costly you're at it you
know maybe is protective against sort of
an ethical compromise but nonetheless I
I do think the paradigm of borrowing
some but you know let me give you an
example when West Wing was on television
maybe actually shortly after it went off
I noticed that there was a pain reliever
at Cameron Bure if it was aspirin or
what it was but I'm very sensitive for
some reason I've never nailed down I'm
pretty good at spotting voices that I
know I can't always peg who it is right
away sometimes takes a half an hour of
listening to figure out who the heck
that is but right this was Donald
Sutherland or somebody it was
Stockard Channing uh-huh and her name
you know no identifying information was
present but the reason that she was
there was clearly that subliminally
people took her to be a doctor because
that was her role the president's wife
was a doctor and so to take somebody who
plays a doctor on television and have
their voice you know in very secure
certain doctorly tones advising you to
take a particular painkiller is more
persuasive than just somebody who might
have
a more resonant voice yeah you know the
reborrowing credibility from a character
and presumably for almost everybody they
didn't even notice that they were
listening to a doctor who they knew
wasn't a doctor giving them medical
advice that they knew wasn't medical
advice right so anyway I'm sure that was
effective too
that's I bet it was a good play yeah so
um as long as we're still in the
neighborhood of lying and truth-telling
and that sort of thing I know you got a
lot of pushback on your book relative to
the question of children and there
obviously there's a lot of richness to
the question about whether or not one
must lie to children whether it's
acceptable to lie to children in a place
that it wouldn't be acceptable to lie to
adults or whether children are just
another example where it seems like it's
okay to lie to them and it really in
general isn't and I raised this because
I find myself I don't know if you would
call it lying but I find myself
misleading my children constantly mm-hmm
and you know as I did with students I do
this with a I resort to humor and other
things but there is a purpose behind it
I'm quite aware of the purpose and in my
kids case I describe it as immunizing
them to the vast sea of [__] that I
know that they will encounter when they
are interfacing with the world as adults
directly you have an example Wow I don't
have one offhand I'm sure I could come
up with a dozen given a couple minutes
to think but you know what I will do is
I will tell them fictions that they
should be able to spot our fictions but
are dressed up as reality and I will see
you know if they don't catch on
I will mislead them to a greater and
greater degree until they finally do
catch on so anyway I sort of have the
sense that I'm training a detector in
them now this is not it doesn't look
like a parent training a child it looks
like us engaging in you know fun right
it's sort of the same way in my
household
wordplay was a constant you know he's
wordplay dishonest because it involves
you know puns that you know misuse words
and things I'm surely it's not and
nobody would say it is it's good-natured
and frankly I think it is great training
but I know that I'm a a coldly rational
being would have to say that I am lying
to my children when I mislead them my
ultimate purpose is not to mislead them
it's the opposite but what do you think
am i over a line there well I think I
would need a clear example of this but I
mean generally speaking you know there
there's flexibility here would like
maybe the intent is not to deceive I
mean this would let me just step back
here when you're talking about children
there is it's relevant that they're
children right I mean children are not
full moral or rational agents and we
don't treat the massage right so you
there's a level of paternalism quite
literally built into your conversation
with your own kids and that's
appropriate for me navigating that has
never required that I lie to my
daughters but it does require that I
shape the truth in certain ways which
excludes Gina just how you know scary
and horrible human life can be right
there's no reason for my daughter even
my oldest daughter to know exactly how
bad the Islamic state is right you just
you need to get into details of sexual
slavery and decapitation and all the
rest right there's no upside to it it
would it would just freak her out for
obvious reasons and you know she's she's
turning 11 and there's she there's
there's time enough in human life to
discover how bad things can get and you
know that's I don't know what I don't
know where the line is I don't know if
you need to be 14 or 15 or 16 but at a
certain point you know you you need to
be treated like an adult on these topics
but the point is not at you know a month
before her 11th birthday and yet that
doesn't require that I lie about
anything it just requires that I be
honest with her that you know listen
there's stuff you don't need to know now
you don't want to know
now you don't there's there's video I
could put on for you that you don't want
to see right that you will feel bad
having seen so she knows that right and
that's a totally honest communication
and that suffices right so it's like it
so she knows she knows I'm not lying to
her and she knows that that I'm not even
really keeping a secret from her it's an
open secret the fact that there is a
secret is not secret and and I'm
discharged and clearly all along the way
she's getting the sense that I'm on her
team right I'm advocating for her in
relationship to a wider reality that she
doesn't she knows she doesn't understand
yet and so that's that's how I see my
role there and it just I mean they're
there probably are cases where it's it's
more covert than that where I'm not
telling her that I'm not telling her
something right I'm just not telling her
something so if she has to take a
medication that has a range of possible
side effects that are you know low
probability enough that I'm willing to
give her the medication in the first
place I've already judged that she
doesn't have to worry about you know
seizures and death when I give her this
medication so I'm not gonna tell her
that that's on the you know on the menu
for for you know some small number of
you know I you know in any population
because it would just serve to freak her
out for you know to no good end and I'm
not gonna and but and yet to fully
unpack that those background facts were
heard and this is you know every drug
has you know potential side effects
which I'm not going to tell you about
would introduce all the kind of a level
of nocebo response that you know I don't
want to introduce into the system so I'm
just not going to talk about it but
that's that that's not lying that's just
it's just not given information that
wouldn't be useful so I guess the
question then you said
that your your mode of editing and
adjusting what you tell your daughter is
it suffice this was your your term what
if it doesn't now your daughter is young
how old is she
soon to be 11 soon to be like let's not
that young so in our household Heather
and I have a sort of core principle of
parenting which has some very
uncomfortable implications but the
principle is the job of a parent is to
[Music]
model the world that the child will
mature into in such a way that they are
well built to deal with it when they get
there and you are as well-versed as
anybody in the defects of the world that
our children are going to mature into
and so if you knew that you were
creating a vulnerability for your
daughter because you were insulating her
from one of the great tragedies of
modernity which is the degree to which
communication is saturated in fiction
malevolent fiction would you would you
alter your stance well I'm sure that's
true on a hundred fronts but
paradoxically I don't accept it so to
let's think how to describe this well if
it was so there are any number of
misfortunes that could befall my
daughter's which in the final analysis
would have served or at least would seem
to have served to give them grit
resilience you know what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger on some level I
mean we just we know this from our own
experience you know we all were all
trailing experiences where we wouldn't
want to do that again
we wouldn't wish it upon somebody but it
actually made us a better person right
and yet knowing that doesn't make me
want to engineer a series of
catastrophes for my daughters
thinking that it's gonna build character
now I think there are types of training
that are effect that that effectively
connect those dots that are you know
totally good to engage I'm something
like Brazilian jiu-jitsu or meditation
retreats or I mean things that are
stressful but they're stressful in a
context where you're the whole point is
you're learning the skills to to adapt
to these stresses and it's it so it's
not haphazard it's not just let's see
what happens to you when we throw you
off this train
it's there's a there's a curriculum here
and there's a path that the many people
have walked before you and we know
something about what it's like to adapt
to these stresses so you know as my
girls get older I'll be looking for
opportunities to to do something like
that but yeah there's no question that
they're sheltered in ways which which
are an expression of you know but my my
Inanna cos good intentions for them but
there's the shadow side of these good
intentions which is yeah these are you
know virtually everyone living in these
contexts is becoming some version of a
hothouse flower that would have not
performed well you know in some
something more like the state of nature
or in some conditions yet to come right
that that perhaps are foreseeable so
yeah it's something I worry about as a
parent I mean these are these are very
privileged childhoods that you know I
mean just at the privilege of having a
happy family you know have having two
parents who love each other who
communicated who are honest who are
doing their best to give you the
whatever they can imagine to be the best
childhood that they can give you like
they're very few people in human history
who have been in precisely that
circumstance but the flip side of that
is that to have been deprived of that
circumstance in one way or another is
what many people can point to as the
thing that built in a character and and
grit and resilience for themselves so I
don't know how to square that circle
yeah I saw somebody
I can remember where I encountered it it
may not have been on Twitter but
somebody tweeted at one point that they
were hoping that their children would
have just enough trauma to make them
funny right yeah yeah there's some truth
in that I think yeah well it's an
interesting puzzle and I do I like the
idea you know your point about your kid
sue being a stand-in for something and
because it's ancient the standing is
likely to be pretty well thought out
from the perspective of bootstrapping
some developmental pathways that
otherwise might get missed on the other
hand is question about how good a match
it is for a world as different as ours
is from the ancestral world Rick all
right so maybe it's time to move on to
free will which is the reason I
controlled you into having a server
session with me so I'm not quite sure
how to start with you because I have the
sense that somebody like you who's taken
a position on a topic like freewill
has a taxonomy in your mind of what the
alternative positions are and I don't
know for sure whether my position is on
the map or not but I do think it takes
some some doing to get to a place where
you can see a topic that you know as
well as this one from a new place which
I'd love to try sure so let's start this
way have you ever been in New York yes
yes you have many times yeah and now I
don't think you have I've always wanted
to go I should say that I've never gone
because of Zeno's paradox which has
prevented me from going and clearly has
prevented you equally from going right
but how did I get halfway to New York
man well that's the question how did you
get halfway to New York then how did you
get halfway there anyway the the reason
I raised Zeno's paradox here and your
failure to get to New York has to do
with the fact that I don't think there
is a flaw in the argument of Zeno's
paradox but there is what is it well
it's it's a it's a kind of semantics can
we know there's a mathematical flaw
because you can summon in
an infinite series right so you can get
to you can land and it took
mathematicians I think some centuries to
spell out what was wrong mathematically
with the paradox but it's just it's
semantically it's a false framing of the
problem you know it's just the idea that
you can't get all the way there is
stated as kind of a term of the of the
the framing and then if you accept that
term well then you just keep cutting
things in half and you know lo and
behold you never arrive but you know
when an arrow leaves a bow it doesn't go
just halfway and then half way again and
half way again it goes as far as it goes
and sometimes that's all the way to the
target and it's I mean there there are
other trying to think of another example
I think there are other cleanings that
this is a different example but there's
a different problem philosophically but
there's their problems like this in
philosophy where you have kind of an
unspecified object which in an effort to
specify its exact boundaries between
existence and non-existence you seem to
run into a paradox but it's not really a
paradox just a nature of you know having
a fuzzy boundary to a certain concept so
you like the concept of a heap right
like when when does a heap come into
existence if you have a you know heap of
corn kernels you know one kernel is not
a heap two kernels is not a heap three
doesn't say yet seem like a heap it's a
it's impossible it seems to specify when
a heap is born because you're just
adding individual kernels and a certain
point you know million kernels is
clearly a pretty big heap right so at
some point you get there but it seems
like there there's no boundary there to
actually find and that's just the nature
of the case it's not that you can't get
a heap out of adding individual kernels
of corn well
that's not that's not why I raised it I
certainly agree with the fact that
there's a delineation problem my example
would be as you go from a mountain to a
valley when have you transitioned from
one to the other and the answer is there
is no point but you certainly are more
likely to find the river in the valley
than on the mountaintop so clearly they
exist so anyway I accept that and I you
know I should also say from my
perspective I don't believe that there
are any real
paradoxes or even could be real
paradoxes in the universe paradox is a
byproduct of the absence of some factor
from your knowledge space and that in
effect you can use it as an indicator
well well I would doubt that was so the
paradox could also be just the fact that
we don't have the right intuitions to
understand what is in fact the case so
our sense of what must be logically so
you know something either is or is not a
heap right it just may be that we live
in a universe where you know kind of
that binary logic just doesn't apply so
I mean to more-relevant an example would
be you know the wave-particle duality
for something like light that just seems
inscrutable but maybe that's the way the
universe is and the fact that it's
inscrutable just needs to stop bothering
us right but it can seem like a paradox
but I think I think we're saying the
same thing in effect what I would say is
you if you're bothered by the fact that
you can't define a moment at which a a
pile becomes a heap or whatever whatever
the thing is that is transitioning from
one state to another then there's
something you don't understand which is
for example the difference between a
discrete binary and a bimodal
distribution or you don't understand
something about the function of language
and the breakdown when it's trying to
describe things that it's ill suited to
or something like that so that is an
absence of a kind of knowledge and what
it means to me and what I've said to my
students very frequently is that paradox
is like an X on a treasure map to the
extent that you have a paradox it means
there's something to be discovered dig
here
and so anyway that's very valuable with
respect to Zeno's paradox and its
relevance here I don't think Zeno's
paradox is necessarily solved in fact
some of the you know the my
understanding of the original meaning of
it was that it created skepticism of the
possibility of motion his motion and
illusion because Zeno's paradox if you
follow it to its logical conclusion
means you can't get anywhere it's
impossible so obviously we do go places
and Zeno himself knew that but the idea
that our mathematical system may be
incapable of at some moment describing
the process by which that happens
because of something in it that is
incapable of addressing the puzzle is
just such an answer so you
simultaneously know the math says X and
the reality says Y and reconciling them
is bound to be productive and it can be
that what is missing is you know the
concept of zero was missing from Greek
mathematics that's a crucial concept and
there are lots of things you can't do
without it and so something was hinting
at the absence of zero likewise Monda
broats
he didn't invent the idea but his
pursuit of fractals was necessary the
math of fractals that was implied by
certain nonsensical mathematical
paradoxes was necessary to begin to
unpack biology there are features of
biology that just don't work with the
standard math and so anyway these these
paradoxes are pointing in a direction
the reason I raise this one here is that
I have the sense looking at your
argument on freewill that it's pretty
close to bullet proof but it's being
pretty close to bullet proof is
compelling if it's the only argument on
the table and it's pretty close to
bullet proof and not compelling in the
same way if there are arguments that are
similarly compelling on the other side
in other words I don't think that the
argument as you lay it out is completely
decisive and that said I would imagine
that's
but he whose explored the topic as you
have hears that and you think oh no I'm
sitting across from another person who
doesn't get the problem with free will
and you're not I would say my battle on
this topic with people has been to
compel them of just what a what a small
fraction of the public conception of
free will one actually has but the
question I think the thing that
separates you and me is you believe free
will is actually a nonentity mm-hm and I
believe it is a dim shadow of what
people would like it to be and what many
people think it is but not non-existent
and that the fact of its being difficult
to attain but not non-existent is
actually a vital fact one that's
necessary and one that's reflected
actually in a lot of the things that
people know about how you run your life
right well so let me make a few
distinctions which I think will be
useful because it's easy to lose sight
of what the the actual territory here is
so to say that free will is an illusion
or is nonsensical
whether we don't have it is not to say
that there's no such thing as freedom or
autonomy or a difference between being
coerced in one circumstance or free to
do what you want and another I mean
those those we have to preserve those
obvious differences in human life and
our preferences there and I share those
preferences you know and to not be in a
prison camp in North Korea is a good
thing and what's bad about being forced
to be there is or all the obvious bad
things about being deprived of freedom
and to have no governance over your your
day to day existence so the problem with
free will is that well let's look at the
basic claim there's the sense the the
the libertarian set was called in
philosophy the libertarian sense of free
will which is
I would argue people's default sense of
it this is a notion that the problem
with it is that it really is impossible
to map on to the physics of things
whatever they are so any my argument is
that any statement of causality whether
you're talking about a deterministic
universe where you know effects follow
from causes ad infinitum and these
causes of necessity precede anyone's
conscious intent I mean your conscious
intent is is something that that is
happening on the back of you know in our
case neurophysiology and gene
transcription and you know on backward
to the Big Bang that isn't a basis for
this notion of libertarian free will and
but nor is any invocation of randomness
into the picture so however you add
randomness you know quantum or otherwise
to determinism you don't get freedom you
just get you know the rolling of dice
right the freedom that people think they
have is a kind of self authorship right
where there's nothing
or there's nothing that they're back
that is fundamentally mysterious to them
that is the actual effective cause of
what they think and do and want and
intend they are the the thinker and the
doer in the wander and the entender and
by they they mean their conscious Minds
right they don't mean this oblivion at
their back that is that they can tell me
in the sum total of the stuff that goes
on inside of their skin they know their
I mean that they're they're people who
pivot to that argument that's it's the
whole person it's my unconscious mind in
addition to my conscious mind but no the
reason why free will seems like a
durable problem for philosophy is that
there's something that people feel they
experience directly they feel conscious
intent as being the proximate cause of
that what that what they voluntarily do
and they feel that they are the the true
extreme cause and one feature of that
feeling or one thing that it suggests is
the sense that if you could rewind the
movie of a person's life right to a few
seconds ago or a few minutes ago or you
know days or weeks or years at any one
of those choice points they could have
done otherwise right that it that it's
meaningful to say to someone you should
have done you did X but you should have
done Y right and that given another
opportunity would the universe being and
precisely the state that it was they
could have done Y right that they're not
merely robots or or you know some form
of some concatenation of causes you know
that is then there's not a they're not a
string of neuro physiological dominoes
that have been falling their whole life
long they are agents that really could
have done otherwise and there's no
account of causality that makes that
seem anything other than illusory again
you have to add the caveat around
randomness because yes randomness
introduces the prospect that they could
have done otherwise but as for reasons
that they can't own right if I told you
you could have you could have married a
different person that really was within
the bounds of of the you know the the
the causal properties of reality to
happen but it could have only happened
if you know we were if there was it had
been some someone rolling dice
differently in your brain right if there
had been a a different you know
degradation of a radioisotope or
something which would have led you to do
something differently and that that's
not the freewill anyone thinks they have
so let's let's take a couple things just
Auto a table so we don't end up tripping
over okay one I don't think we can rule
out at a formal level a totally
deterministic you
verse but I think at a practical level
we can I think it is actually completely
inconsistent with any belief in
Darwinism that what you have is a
universe in which there was no
opportunity for anything else to ever
happen for its entirety from moment one
then Darwinism is an illusion and
nothing in fact makes any sense
including this conversation it's all
some sort of odd theater and maybe the
thing that makes least sense of all is
consciousness that there should be an
awareness taking place inside of a
totally scripted entity makes no sense
so anyway let's put it this way
well let's bracket that because I mean
that that I think is I think it's
interesting to consider whether our
notion of possibility is just a fantasy
right right and as I said you can't rule
it out completely or it would be that
the whole thing I mean you know frankly
it could be that we exist inside a
deterministic computer in which somebody
had a purpose in getting us to have this
conversation and feel some way within it
and you know all sorts of things have to
be left formally on the map but I think
at a practical level a there's no
percentage in it if this really is a
totally deterministic universe then it's
hard to even know how to complete that
sentence the level of pointlessness of
anything other than simply doing what
you deterministically have no choice but
to do is what it is and so let's you
know but but even in even in that case
there still is a there's a consequence
to not knowing what's going to happen
and there is the reality that a parent
choice still plays a role in deciding
what in fact happens is it usually
mechanistic one yeah but you can't just
wait to see what happens because that is
itself a choice which baguettes certain
consequences and closes the door to
other kind of have to say inside of a
completely deterministic universe I
don't even know what you're talking
about
what do you mean consequence it's it's
well but that's it's so fully automatic
well yes but it but it is in on some
level where as Zeno by another root
because yes in a fully it's just a
single object writer there and there
knows there's no such thing as events
there's no such thing as causality it's
just a block universe on some level
right and future exists as much as the
past so actually let's let's go back to
you know cuz I don't think we got the
value out of it oh come in in just
setting the stage here for the
discussion that I hope will have the
thing about Zeno's paradox is that
actually xenos Zeno style logic is
recovered by some models that are taken
seriously in physics in other words in
many worlds interpretation for example
in the deposits essentially an
indefinitely large number of universes
that account for all of the possible
trajectories so you know to the extent
that you know I drop an item and it's
one fiber of the carpet versus another
fiber of the carpet you get two
universes spawned in order to account
for everything that is downstream of
that that's it's some sense an obvious
nonsense explanation is it standing in
for something that we can't phrase maybe
because limits of human cognition or
language make it impossible to phrase
and so you know the paradoxes of quantum
mechanics for example it's possible that
there's some way we could construct
let's say it's a language barrier
language that those things wouldn't
sound so outlandish
but we don't have it and so we're
constantly offering them and then stuck
with the disbelief that comes along so
anyway my my point would be you know
you've been to New York and you know
that there is a formal problem given a
particular way of phrasing the process
of getting to New York that you couldn't
have been there and what you're left
with is the argument has a strength and
the empirical fact that the argument
does not appear it apparently prevent
you from getting places also carries
away in fact it carries the dominant
weight and those two things live
together right except I think the the
experiential the experience that
functions in this analogy as knowing
that you've been to New York is and if
there's a novel part to my argument
against freewill it's this one which is
I'm claiming that no one actually has
the experience of free will you think
you do right right and I so I just to
take the straw man off the table and I
know you wouldn't intentionally straw
man but I do not believe that Free Will
exists as people imagine it that there
is an illusion of free will that is very
powerful and to which I think your
argument is primarily addressed and the
problem is that this obscures a
different question which is there is
there something that would justify the
belief in something that would rightly
take the label of free will that is
hidden by a straw man version of free
will that we don't even need to worry
about because you and I both know it
doesn't exist well no we do need to
worry about it because it is the thing
that people are afraid to lose well we
don't have to worry about it because you
and I are on the same team in that fight
right point is by the way you are so
haunted by mechanisms that you had no
hand in creating that holds sway over
every important decision that you're
making that your sense it is clear that
your sense that you are free
moment-to-moment to choose as you would
that sense is an illusion but my
argument what I'm trying to put on the
table is that there is something to
freewill it's a small target but that
that target is the most important thing
about it if it would just simply that
there was some sort of an exception to
your argument this wouldn't be a very
interesting conversation but I think
once you spot the exception if that's
what it is that the desire to enlarge it
is overwhelmed and in fact the irony of
Sam Harris is that many of the things
that occupy your time and your thinking
appear to be attempts to take the wisp
of freewill that we are handed and to
enlarge it and have it applied to a
larger fraction of your life which i
think is a completely rational response
to the discovery of just what a rarefied
commodity freewill is right yeah well so
the
this could be a semantic difference
between us but let's talk about what you
think that that scintilla of freedom
actually is okay so first of all it is
utterly dependent on us not living in a
deterministic universe if we live in a
deterministic universe then I don't
understand a damn thing and it's game
over for Brett assuming we don't and I
think the physics is pretty clear
there's no reason to think we do
there's quantum uncertainty and the fact
that there is quantum uncertainty means
that uncertainty can exist at higher
levels through various mechanisms well
or we live in a universe where I mean if
you take the many-worlds picture
seriously which again it's hard to do
but many physicists do at this point we
live in a world where everything that
can happen does in fact happen somewhere
right and you don't know which one of
these worlds you are in right so it's
it's a new kind of determinism in a way
which is like you know every every
gradation of possible difference in in
the in this probability space which is
this conversation between us is spawning
yet another universe in which precisely
that thing is happening you know you
know as as deterministically is one
billiard ball hitting another but the
uncertainty is we don't know which one
we don't know whether we're in the
universe where we both start speaking
Mandarin right now for reasons we can't
understand or we're in the universe I'm
pretty sure we're in the universe where
we're going to stay stick with English
but whatever surprises are here are
still can still beyond just understood
determinate deterministically in that
picture well I've never regretted not
speaking Mandarin what I do right now
but so here's the thing I do I I resent
the many-worlds interpretation
I'm actually not convinced that it's
exactly wrong but I am convinced that at
best it is a very stupidly explained way
of phrasing something that nobody can
seem to phrase
so that it is not insane well it is the
crit is that I think on its face the
hardest thing to believe that still is
seemingly believed or at least paid
lip-service by a it might even be a
majority now of physicists Mabel said
last poll I heard it was something like
thirty five percent but it's it's it's
getting there and it's it is the
strangest picture of reality that you
could you could imagine I think you're
being too nice it's stupid
the idea that universes are spawned to
deal with the difference between the
thing I dropped hitting one carbon fiber
and the next I'm sorry that's not how
nature works it's it's a different view
of parsimony than then I have
intuitively it's a total rejection of
parsimony just be most it is the
opposite of parsimony well they they
actually I put this to I think was max
tegmark in a podcast I did with him I
think it was Max and it was just a just
a different view of parsimony it was not
you know it was kind of privileged in
the the mathematical parsimony over the
the bricks-and-mortar parsimony I think
that that I mean it did many worlds what
I said was not the result of adding lots
of assumptions or you know epicycles or
something that was jig arena theory
it was just a brave acceptance of the
consequences of what this you know there
there we should say that and I you know
I'm not a physicist you know we dragged
your brother in here to get into more of
these details but there's no picture of
quantum reality that tracks our common
sense intuitions about how the world
should be so you're left except in
something at least at this point that
seems frankly bizarre but many worlds
seems about as bizarre as as anything I
could imagine
no you're not left with accepting it and
again I'm not rejecting it in a formal
sense it may be an insane phrasing of
something that could be phrased
rationally
some other perspective but as phrased it
really is the rejection of the idea of
parsimony and not for a good reason just
because I mean actually Eric does have a
term for this sort of thing I hope he
won't resent my applying it here I think
he would but desperation physics but
it's not even just to forget about many
worlds for a second just imagine a
universe that is infinitely large right
now one of the the probabilistic
consequences of that scenario is that if
you just go far enough in any direction
again you run into the same problem
anything that can happen will happen an
infinite number of times right I mean
that's how big infinity is so that there
are an infinite number of identical
copies of us having infinitely similar
and and slightly different conversations
than this an infinite number of times
simply if you make the universe big
enough and that's it that just falls out
of probability theory right but here's
this is my point about fractals actually
and you know I'm speaking a little bit
out of my depth here but my
understanding is that there's a problem
with coastlines which is that they get
infinitely long the closer you measure
they approach infinity in length as you
get better at measuring the nuances of a
coastline right that obviously doesn't
make any sense the coastline isn't
getting bigger because you're measuring
more finally well I know it makes sense
I mean your your ruler has to get
infinitely thin and small I mean like
you like but the point is as we go down
to the Planck scale and as you ask them
Toth to infinity right right you
discover I screwed up somewhere and it
isn't my ruler ice it's just not usually
well this cake it sort of comes back to
Z no yes is it you've applied Zeno's
paradox to measure in a closed line
bingo but the point is there is a way to
do this and it took somebody stepping
back and saying you know what math is
going to have to be we're gonna need a
new toolkit just the same way newton and
leibniz
discovered a toolkit for people don't
like it when I say it this way but for
calculating the incalculable which is
what calculus did as I see it but anyway
the point is I think the many-worlds
interpretation is
a best answer to a problem that is
phrased so incorrectly that we can't
that just as if you asked the question
about where these creatures came from
3,000 years ago nobody had Darwinism to
offer so there wasn't even a way to
begin to phrase the answer credibly hmm
you could say well then that leaves you
picking between deities who might have
done it and really what we're after is
figuring out which one it was when in
fact it wasn't any of them it was
processes that were understandable but
we didn't yet have the mechanism to do
so so I think that's where we are in
that case yeah it might be and it's hard
to see what we're not seeing here I
can't even dimly imagine but it it does
seem like I mean is it is a fairly
straightforward claim that the again the
the the infinite case is even simpler
because it's just you know it doesn't
require any notion of universes
splitting but it's it's hard to know
where to where to bite the bullet I
think I think the thing to recognize
would the these counterintuitive
consequences of infinity it's just how
counterintuitive infinity is I mean
infinity is not just really really big
right right it is and and our intuition
that that it's just really really big
know the rules change when you when you
put that symbol of infinity on the on
the paper right rather there's a very
big number if we can agree that in an
infinitely large universe somewhere at
some point in fact an infinite number of
places an infinite number of times a
asteroid will have hit another asteroid
and aardvark will have been formed
absent an atmosphere immediately died
and disintegrated into a bizarrely large
petunia of a unusual color right an
infinite number of times
I'm telling inverse compatible with the
law of laws of physics will have happen
an infinite number of times yes I don't
believe that has
ever happened anywhere in the universe
and I believe that actually what we will
ultimately come to understand is that
the universe has to be limited in a way
that that actually won't have occurred
ever well but one easy way to bound that
is just say that it's we don't live in
an infinite universe however big it is
it's just it's not very close a being
right infinite yes okay now worried
about this particularly definitely large
isn't infinite and the differences you
yeah yeah well I agree
so all right back to free but I just
I'll tell you I think you if you want to
close the door to many worlds or at
least beat your intuitions into shape
there I think you should probably have
either David Deutsch or Sean Carroll on
your podcast because they're both all in
on that all in I love it when people die
all I'd want to do is bet against it you
know I'm certain to be right and it's
easy money so okay
back to free will let's take off the
table a completely deterministic
universe because even if that was the
answer there's nothing to be done in a
deterministic universe in a discussion
that would be you know the discussion
will be what it is well again I think
that's not a necessary conclusion
psychologically because you still don't
you still don't know what is gonna
happen next right what something will
happen now what does it mean to know
well to be able to talk about to be able
to sell more able to I mean none of this
makes any sense in a completely but it
mean if it makes psychological sense
nothing makes any psychological sense no
you still have to get lunch
you still want no there's no half to get
there's no nothing there is and the
illusion that we are having a
conversation the conversation is a
conversation because we're not deciding
what to say and our blood pressures
rising because do we have a disagreement
isn't it's nothing it's just the thing
unfolding it's it's a mill okay so that
it's a rock tumbling down a hill I may
not understand your concern here but
this this seems close to me
psychologically close to me to a point
that is often made that I often find
surprising because in my mind it means
the opposite of what its purveyors seem
to think it means and many people have
made this
it's a very common objection to an
argument against free will
I saw it made by Noam Chomsky somewhere
at the end of a lecture that's on
YouTube I know many people I can think
of who made this argument which is okay
if we have no free will
what's the point of reasoning at all
what's the point of talking about this
at all you're you're arguing as though
you're are the fact that you're arguing
about free will the fact that you're
trying to convince me that it's an
illusion presupposes rationality which
priests of which presupposes freedom of
will but in my world it presupposes
nothing of the kind of rationality is
one of these cases where our absence of
free will is is should be salient to us
if I even just take the easiest case if
I ask you to add up a column of numbers
right invoking the the the algorithm of
addition you have zero freedom as to I
mean if you're gonna do it right or
wrong that's total freedom yeah and and
and it's you you you know you how you
apply those rules is is utterly
determined by what those rules in fact
are and you you will get that you will
get the right answer and you'll either
be enslaved by that process successfully
or you'll fail and in either case you
have you can't claim to have freely
chosen but I think you just you just
swapped in free will for determinism my
concern the thing I want to take off the
table is the idea that any of this means
anything in a completely deterministic
universe as far as I'm concerned as long
as we can get out of a completely
deterministic universe we still have
something to talk about with respect to
free well in a completely deterministic
universe not only do you win the
freewill argument but there's nothing to
argue about argument itself doesn't make
any sense it's just another process
unfolding the idea that there's any
consciousness to be had is the most
absurd irony that could possibly be well
so does it means listening a telescope
to the sky and even figure out how big
the universe is in a deterministic
universe well so in
at the end of the day or you know at the
end of the epoch at the end of the
universe it will you will see that it
had just been one long row of dominoes
if you're still preserving this notion
of process or you'll just say there's it
process itself was an illusion there's
just it's like this Sun novel that's
already been written and we're on page
17 now but page 175 exists just as
surely as this page does and you know if
there's no there is no process there's
no there's no development there's just a
mechanism unfolding right and but
there's no there's no unfolding in the
end there's just like there's there's
there are no events no it's it's
unfolding in the sense that a Rube
Goldberg machine ultimately you know
puts the toast in the toaster or
whatever it does right well so if you're
going to stay with the process if you're
going to go along for the ride you know
ride through the the Rube Goldberg
machine if you're gonna be the ball
that's being you know knocked around in
the machine as opposed to standing
outside the Machine and viewing it as a
totality right then psychologically the
next moment is still uncertain for you
right so you're like you have you have a
range of options you have an apparent
range of options it feels like you have
arranged the question is why does it
feel anything because so we yeah look I
can't prove that we're not in a totally
deterministic universe what I can say is
that the phenomena inside of this
totally deterministic universe don't
make any sense relative to it they're
all they do chowk knows a mechanism for
particles to get from A to B that we're
inevitably going from A to B yeah Bo but
who care I mean that that's you wouldn't
care you wouldn't know
cruel joke doesn't doesn't constrain our
thinking about the nature of reality
determinism constrains every bit of
thinking that ever happened every
discovery that was ever made the idea
that there is evolution and a completely
deterministic universe makes no sense
because every interaction that ever
happened between any two creatures was
completely
/ scripted from the first moment that
the universe came into being so what it
was it wouldn't seem like it it wouldn't
seem like it but that question is
psychologically that's but the truth is
it can seem like it's it and then this
the other issue I have with freewill
which is if you pay it if you pay close
enough attention to what it's like to be
you you can notice that everything is
just happening right you like you don't
know what you're going to think until
you think it right till the thought
itself arises and it arises in the same
adventitious way that you know a
hummingbird could fly in your window
right like it's it is you did you're not
standing in relationship of authorship
to there is in fact no you that is
standing there pushing the thoughts into
view I'm not arguing that it couldn't be
in fact of course it could be let's
imagine an infinitely powerful relative
to our universe an infinitely powerful
critter that decided to put together a
deterministic computer in which we would
have the unfolding of the universe and
we would live it just as we do and there
was no chance of anything ever coming
out I know I know but you seem to be
arguing that if it were so then one
either we couldn't have the exact
experience we're having now or if we did
it would be a cruel joke and and and
that would and the fact that it would be
a cruel joke would require something
different of us in the next moment
there's no if there's no choice for
anything different in the next moment
all I'm saying is that first of all I'm
a dyed-in-the-wool Darwinist I believe
Darwinism works because there are
multiple outcomes and better outcomes
propagate in a completely deterministic
universe you might see the same thing
unfolding but there would be no meaning
to any of it and well meaning again
meaning is a I think meaning is another
one of these fishy concepts that's that
can be can be applied appropriately in
within certain frames but it's not it's
not an ultimate concept it's not a
concept that can be applied everywhere
without creating howlers or
well that's the thing is patience if
this is mean look I'm surprised that
we're stuck on a completely
deterministic universe as a possibility
well I just don't see is if it's pot if
it's the case so it's a so that we're
not talking past each other let's let's
just revisit one point here the it is
usually felt I mean I I think it will be
keenly felt by almost everyone listening
to us that the problem of free will
indoors because on the experiential side
we sort of know we have it we feel it
right like our experience is not
compatible with it being an illusion
yeah right and so if you're gonna tell
me it's an illusion you're telling me I
didn't go to New York right and so I
know something's fishy there because I I
can choose right now to have tea or
coffee yeah right it's what's on me and
I can do it you know that sense of being
in charge right that is that requires
some additional observation of what it's
like to be you but that you can get past
that and realize that your experience
moment a moment is totally compatible
with free will being an illusion so I
just want to plant a flag there where
people can see it I agree with that
statement that okay look you and I are
on the same page with respect to the
question of how do we feel we feel free
what does that imply about how free we
are almost nothing free will is a useful
fiction the way most people understand
it but let me point out but I would make
the additional point that when I pay
attention which is you know more and
more of the time I don't actually feel
free in that in that sense like I what I
feel like is the the witness to the
fundamental mystery of being in each
moment which is thoughts just appear
intentions just appear some of them are
seem actionable some of them don't
the why I why there's a why one has
enough
charge in one moment to being actionable
and in another moment it fails to move
me all of that is is irreducibly
mysterious right and there's no there's
no place I'm standing as a conscious
witness to this process where it feels
like I have the free will that most
people seem to be talking about oh I
definitely think the door you have
walked through is worth walking through
in part because it gives you greater
access to the very limited rarefied and
I would argue highly desirable freedom
that is possible ok so let's talk about
what that may or may not be ok yeah what
what that may or may not be so let's
just notice something you have two
children yep that's weird they're a
highly bred prime number you're a highly
successful handsome guy you surely had
you decided to do it could have arranged
to have a great deal more children than
two well I'm not sure about that but are
you suggesting that I should be more
moved by by Darwinian logic than I in
fact am no I'm saying that if there were
no free will then we know that one of
the components of the equation that
ought to be driving you ahead without
your ability to intervene meaningfully
on your own behalf would be a fitness
maximizing function and we would expect
you to have a great deal more children
than that given your privileged position
in the universe and no no so that said
that suggests that the the determinism
would cause us to be more slavishly
devoted to ancient APIs genetically
driven urges than we are and that
that's the kind of you know some are all
these other countervailing forces that
have civilized us are not yet just more
determinism right but so my point is if
your argument were true as you stated it
which it may be and alone on the floor
of arguments relative to this puzzle
which I believe it isn't if it were both
of those things then I believe one of
the factors that robs you of free will
would see fitness as a primary function
and that what in fact has happened is
not that civilization has come to a
wiser understanding of how many children
to have what's happened is an accident
of history that the act of sexual
intercourse and the phenomenon of sexual
reproduction have turned out to be
divorced from each other biologically
there was no need to drive our ancestors
to enjoy reproducing because driving
them to pursue sex was sufficient to get
reproduction to happen the fact of those
two things being diff different from
each other
leaves room for us to intervene
technologically so that you can engage
in family planning and decide not only
how many children you want but when you
want to have them read you know all
sorts of things so the fact of family
planning is in many instances at least
anti-darwinian I'm not arguing against
it I'm not a fan of being a slave to
fitness
in fact I've argued publicly that we
must rebel against those drives that
would have us maximize Fitness because
they're going to get us killed but the
fact that we find it relatively easy to
engage in family planning and that we
would find it very much more difficult
to to swear off sex mm-hm
tells us something you have two
different levels of freedom with respect
to those two choices and the reason that
you have two different levels is
arbitrary right and not secured on the
basis of any intention or or any free
will of my own right like I'm a mere
of that difference well I understand
that your argument your argument is not
wrecked by the observation that you have
two different levels of freedom relative
to reproductive behavior and
reproduction itself and well and also
the the what you're calling a different
level of freedom is by with some other
emphasis just seen as freedom to be
pushed around by other forces yep in
this case cultural totally totally get
your argument but let's let's try an
experiment as I was reading your book on
freewill I imagined a person actually
quite a plausible person I think people
have a way of reading more agnostically
than they might but somebody who read
your book not so agnostically and
understood the depth and completeness of
the argument that you were laying out
might be thoroughly disturbed by the
discovery of just how little freedom
they had over their own lives and it is
not implausible that somebody who found
themself horrified by the discovery that
free will was essentially non-existent
might seek to generate it that they
might attempt to live in such a way so
that they would go from a state of
having no freedom to at least having
some and what's more it would not be I
think incorrect to think well maybe it's
too late for me but maybe I can generate
I can bootstrap some freedom for people
five generations down my lineage and you
know I can at least do them that favor
and it's similar motivation as I might
have to want to see the ecological
problems of the world addressed so that
future generations have a nice planet to
live on and and enjoy so were such a
person to exists were somebody to have
that reaction to your argument and to
seek to generate freedom I believe that
they would actually have a path to doing
so and it would involve at first the use
of randomness to generate to see
Asians that were not otherwise going to
emerge from their cognitive processes so
if I were to you know get a fancy set of
dice and I were to put in some time
figuring out how let's say I've started
out with vacations and I said well I am
going to set up my computer to take the
inputs that I put in from dice rolls
that I am convinced are actually random
and I'm going to vacation at the closest
coordinate to by some scheme what I've
rolled to the dice right I could specify
some limits so that I wouldn't end up
you know on a desolate atoll or
something like that but anyway you could
generate a series of experiences in life
that were only the process of the one
decision to embrace randomness as a
chooser and then whatever consequence
has happened you would have whatever
discussions you had in the locations
that had been chosen for you you would
see whatever sunsets you saw and that
this would generate a mind that at some
point would be very different
from the mind that had been constrained
by some plotting series of decisions
that followed from each other and
generated their own their own follow-on
phenomenon yeah but no more free I'm not
sure about that I mean it is it would be
different but it's just as hostage to
proximate causes that were uncomfortable
I mean in this case a literally
uncomfortable like if you're rolling
dice to decide what to do next eat next
say next who to be in the world like
beautiful choosing a career choosing a
major you you can you're you're being
played upon by a process that doesn't in
that case doesn't even feel like you're
owning your own agency right now you're
you're giving your agency away to to
quite literally giving it away to chance
yeah and a grand show is a very
different life than the person would be
tending to lead if they didn't
that but it's it's not what it's not it
doesn't align with the freedom that that
anyone thinks they have or could
reasonably want nor am I trying to
resurrect the conventional notion of
free will okay why would I am getting
I'm not arguing that as you're being
bounced around the globe by the roll of
dice that you are free right you are
enslaved to a different process but what
I am arguing is that if you do that long
enough what you do is you take the
inputs that hold us captive and you
drive their influence over yourself and
your descendants toward zero you don't
get to zero but you drive let's say the
the fact that you know you're born in
Los Angeles you go to a certain school
certain ideas are resonant during the
period of time all of these things are
causes that then result in you having
certain values those values unfold and
choices those choices manifest in
phenomena on your life that you
experience and so you and I agree that
this has something very that this
reduces the actual freedom that you are
being carried along in a stream much
more than you typically understand if
you generate phenomena by random and
that creates a series of experiences
that are themselves only sequenced by
the one choice that you've made to break
free from being captive then eventually
my argument is you will have generated
enough novelty you're not you haven't
generated a escape from causality that's
what I hear you saying right the
causality is still there after you've
done this for 20 years or you've done it
for 20 generations yeah right you will
always have causality and causality is
always an intruder into consciousness
into the space of consciousness it's
it's always yes it will never not you
can't own it you can't you can't
actually say
that consciousness was the the cause of
that next thing because that next thing
simply appeared this is a separate
conversation about why consciousness is
is so inscrutable and in evolutionary
terms you know it's hard to say what is
doing and and if it's if it's hard to
say what is doing it's hard to say why
it might have evolved in the first place
but yeah so it doesn't it still leaves
us with this this this mystery at the
level of experience that we why we would
ever assert something something like
freedom of will in the first place I'll
grant you it gives you a very different
kind of life but we sort of simulate
that anyway just by being in dialogue
with the world perpetually I mean you're
meeting new people you're reading new
books you're tasting the tastes and
seeing the sights of new cultures you're
stirring the pot if you're if you're
living at all actively and and
cosmopolitan in a cosmopolitan way
you're you're you're rolling dice all
the time you're just not thinking about
it that way well so what I mean I'm by
the way I'm learning a lot about my own
argument in dialog with you which is
which an example of what I just said
essentially is that your day you don't
know what your what you really think
until you try it out and in the company
of others or you write it down and
people react to react to what you wrote
I mean your process of thinking isn't
done you know until you've until you
it's hard to know when it's done right
and then you keep again this is this
everything is every collision is a kind
of roll the dice yes every clusion is a
kind of roll the dice and you know there
was some part of me that really wanted
to have this conversation with you for
exactly this reason is that I did know
that it would force my thinking forward
in a way that wouldn't have happened
otherwise
but I think my argument comes down to
this we have a misunderstanding about
consciousness and I I'm not sure exactly
I have heard you argue that
consciousness is an evolutionary paradox
I actually don't think
it is but I also I think I need to write
what I believe the solution to that
puzzle to be in a forum where people can
digest it and confront it so I'm in a
sidebar that for the moment let's just
say I'm proceeding from a strong belief
that consciousness is absolutely
evolutionary and totally comprehensible
and standard Darwinian terms that said I
believe that there is a border within us
a border I think you'll agree to that a
large fraction of our cognitive activity
even consequential cognitive activity
that affects our behavior is outside of
consciousness and some of it is so far
outside of consciousness that no amount
of training can access it yeah yeah so
that said there's a lot of stuff
shallower that isn't typically conscious
but can be accessed by consciousness
with behavior could be psychedelics it
could be sweat lodges it could be
meditation it could be extreme isolation
lots of things can alter where the
border of consciousness is and that our
conscious mind is actually it is the
part of us that is capable of meaningful
choice it does not have nearly as much
choice as it imagines the experiments
that tell us that in general when people
believe they've made a conscious choice
that the actual choice is not preceded
at least not preceded far enough by a
decision in the conscious mind to be
caused by it that those things are
troubling but the I mean really the
question is can the mind that thinks
it's choosing be trained to increase its
own capacity to alter our path and can
it well maybe that's yes yeah I don't
think the this is where meaning comes
back in 21
you wonder how any of this could impact
a life and spell the difference between
a good life and a bad life or a life
worth living in a and something less and
you know how how the nature of reality
you know how a deterministic picture of
the universe may cancel or seemed to
threaten some of what we think it makes
life worth living or you know creativity
even a concept worth entertaining I
think it's all of it makes sense
all of these distinctions can run
through in the content in the
psychological circumstance of a
deterministic or apparently
deterministic universe because there is
just there's there's a hierarchy of of
what we want and value in each moment
right and again we didn't we we don't we
don't pick this hierarchy there they're
moments where we seem to struggle to
change it or to adhere to deeper values
when more superficial ones come online
and seem to threaten them we can become
at war we can we can fall into conflict
with ourselves and freedom free you know
small F freedom can can seem to depend
on our being able to resolve those
conflicts in ways that we don't regret
right so if you let me take a very easy
case and common one you're trying to eat
more healthfully there's a range of
foods you want to eat but you don't want
to eat them now because your Trent
you're now on a diet right and yet you
know that in a few short hours you're
going to be tempted to eat one of these
foods that is now off your diet right
and so you're in opposition with
yourself and this notion of freedom
right what would it mean to be free in
this circumstance well freedom would
be is it what would it mean to be not
free at all to be just a mere automaton
Matan your slave to your passions in
this regard well then you say you're
going to be on a diet that lasts exactly
14 minutes and then you've got a
spoonful of ice cream in your mouth and
you anything [__] I just screwed up
again right oh yeah why can't I stay on
my diet
right you you part of you wants to be on
a diet and part of you wants to eat ice
cream and and the part that wants to to
eat wins more or less every hour on the
hour and yet the part we're talking to
about the diet is the frustrated part
which says I still want to be on a diet
and I can't I can't manage it out for
some reason I'm not free how how can I
get more freedom in the system right so
that I can actually adhere to what is in
fact a deeper value than just getting
the next bite of ice cream one when the
desire arises that dichotomy of and that
hierarchy or a parent hierarchy of
values again that picture can be
completely deterministic or you can roll
as many dice as you want to try to
jiggle it around but there's still more
and less satisfying ways to navigate all
of that so if somebody comes in and says
actually what you need is a you know you
need a you know a serotonin agonist
that's going to give you a little more
willpower here and we need to get these
foods out of your house in the first
place you just there's a basic principle
of dieting that you know you haven't
heard again through no free will of your
own you just didn't read the right books
okay I'm not quite sure which you know
particles in the universe to credit with
that failure but you know you're you
didn't hear that the first principle is
to just empty your pantry and shelves
and fridge of all of these offending
foods and then you don't need the same
kind of activation energy to keep your
willpower intact because the foods
aren't there right so again this will
have its whatever effect it has on you
right the chi you know and throwing out
the foods will have its mechanistic
effect and all of a sudden
you may find yourself in possession of
much more quote freedom right now you
don't know you you're not having a hot
fudge sundae because you don't have the
ice cream and you don't have the fudge
and you're you you know you're free just
to maintain your diet right which again
you want to be on from you know what
principle in you that you authored no
you you got shamed into this cajoled
into this convinced into this by culture
by you know seeing a scene the sight of
yourself in the mirror that in and not
like in the the the outline something
happened which again you can't fully own
so it is still it's still we're still in
rube rube goldberg land but these
distinctions in degrees of freedom you
know ordinarily conceived
psychologically they can be maintained
and we can still make intelligent
decisions about how to be how to get
more or less more of what we want and
less of what we don't want in this
sphere of a parent choice well I mean I
think your example is a good one and I
think I I get how it makes your point
but I think it also makes mine which is
you clearly have competing modules in
your mind right you have a long-term
module that would like to lose weight
for example and you've got a short term
term module that is aware of what things
it has in the pantry that it might eat
and periodically it checks in with
whether or not your guard is down and
enough to get you to go eat them you can
as you point out engineer a circumstance
in which one of these modules is more
dominant over the other than it
typically is that you know in a
completely deterministic universe that
means exactly nothing in something short
of a completely deterministic universe
well no it does it doesn't mean nothing
because if you're living in the part of
the deterministic universe where you on
this occasion successfully throw out all
the popcorn and and peanut brittle that
you ate last time around
this in this part of the universe in
this period in human history and across
your life line and for again we're still
talking about process you're going to
get thinner through no free will of your
own see I don't understand how we're
tripping over the consequences of a
completely deterministic universe well
you would agree that the universe is if
it's determined it's being determined is
still compatible with saying they're
gonna be fat people and thin people and
we can we can find out whether you're
one of them
well I don't know what we're about to
discover here I have a feeling if we can
figure out why we're disagreeing about
this there's something very important to
be discovered but I'm actually not
compelled we can pull it off okay if we
are in a completely deterministic
universe then none of the words you just
used to describe that have any meaning
whatsoever
this is all yeah but it the question is
how far but we if we zoom out all the
way yes then there's no there's no such
thing as people that's what I mean like
if we're just going to talk about
particles and yeah and fields of force
that's it there are no people there's
nothing there are as if people right
okay but at the level at which we can
dignify the the nouns and verbs that
give us people and their their doings we
can still talk we can still think about
that deterministically okay I think
about anything if it's all determine
look if we zoom all the way out and it's
really full determinism from the moment
the universe was created till the moment
of heat death or whatever happens to it
then this is all the most ridiculous
joke and the idean the ver no word has a
meaning there's nothing there's just
thing it's like billiard balls wondering
about the meaning of trajectory it's it
doesn't make any sense but randomness
doesn't use that burden it does I don't
think we know completely how but what we
know is that there's more than one
outcome possible and therefore I don't
know how it is that when a cheetah
chases a gazelle that
there can be two possible outcomes but I
know that all of Darwinism is stacked on
the idea that two things could have
happened and one of them did so two
things could have happened and one of
them did requires there to be randomness
somewhere in the universe and
unfortunately I do think we have to
reach down all the way to quantum
randomness to bootstrap something at the
level of cheetahs and gazelles that is
capable of explaining anything that we
see including what we experience I think
well this is a penalty something I
haven't thought much about but it seems
to me intuitively that you can still get
Darwinism out of just the mere
frequencies of things happening as they
happen well you you could get so I again
I have to leave it open as a formal
possibility you could get a universe in
which pseudo Darwinistic processes
unfolded completely automatically with
no opportunity for anything else to ever
have happened and all of the creatures
would be produced inevitably in the same
way that a screensaver could produce a
fish tank on a screen that had no two
ways about it
right that's all possible but then I
think we get into a philosophical
question not that there would be any us
to get into anything like philosophy nor
would there be any philosophy but if we
just sort of grant that leeway were we
to be living in a universe in which
every creature that ever existed or will
ever exist was absolutely 100%
predetermined from the first instance
that plasma burst forth from whatever it
was if we lived in that universe then
you would have to say those things were
created right in some sense you would
have to acknowledge that they had been
planned because the process that creates
them absent the plan requires there to
be multiple ways that things can go and
some things to be better at this game
than others well no because it's just
there need not be a plan it's just there
just needs to be causal efficacy
that has no degrees of freedom right
like it doesn't have to be there's no
place to stand where it's thought out in
advance it's just this is here's an
algorithm right so here this is this is
perhaps a better analogy here there's an
algorithm for producing all of the you
know the rational numbers say right I'm
gonna give you that algorithm or the
idea here's a better example an
algorithm for calculating PI right the
decimal expansion of Pi the decimal
expansion of Pi is whatever it is right
and we haven't planned that we don't
have to have it in mind in advance to
run this algorithm right the algorithm
is totally deterministic we have zero
degrees of freedom there's an literally
infinite landscape over which this
algorithm is gonna be run and yet the
five six seven eight come right you know
foreordained right but there's no place
we wouldn't say at the moment of the Big
Bang where we began running this out
algorithm every gazelle and amoeba had
to be you know conceived in the mind's
eye of whatever started the process at
the level of the individuals it doesn't
make any difference but my point is
let's say that you and I had been
standing outside the universe as it
first came into being Ryan before there
was Adam's right we're just looking at
the amorphous hot whatever it is and I
said you know let me show you a
crocodile and I broke out of crocodile
and I said these are gonna happen by the
hundreds of thousands maybe the millions
right at the moment that you have no
order whatsoever right the idea of all
the things that have to happen to get to
a crocodile is it's a profound sequence
it's not in any way remotely like the
sequence after the decimal place in PI
all right that sequence has you know I
know I'm gonna get in trouble
mathematically if I say it has no order
to it because obviously it's order is
implied by the relationship of the
diameter
to the circumference of a circle but it
is not a cumulative building process
that becomes more and more fancy as you
get farther from the decimal place it
just is it's a sequence of numbers
that's unique yeah but on some level
Darwinism doesn't get evolution doesn't
get necessarily fancier as you get it
has in the local case apparently gotten
fancier but there's also been there are
you know Kenzi aids of simplicity there
are instances where it goes the other
direction yeah but in general it started
at no complexity or yeah trivial
complexity and reached amazing levels of
complexity so there's some sort of
ability to generate complexity and the
only reason that works is because
there's a cumulative process in it that
has to do with competition and my point
really and I don't know how I don't know
how productive this is but my point is
not that we can prove that we're not in
a deterministic universe but that
everything philosophical collapses
downstream of that one claim well it it
just depends on what part what what the
framework is in which you are talking
about anything because it's not in a
deterministic universe you can still
talk about crocodiles you just so you
don't think it's like this this argument
sounds like there's no such thing as a
crocodile because all they're all a
crocodile is is carbon and hydrogen and
nitrogen and oxygen right so if you're
talking about the the periodic table
there are no crocodiles and there never
will be crocodiles no no I am talking
about a process that edits down
populations to small numbers of
individuals that have advantages and
those advantages are cumulatively
acquired in some lineages a heritable
substances I'm trying not to limit that
to DNA but basically I'm talking about
DNA my point again I'm not arguing that
deterministic universe is inconceivable
I'm arguing that the content of the
universe is a bizarre paradox it's a
joke if it's downstream of a totally
deterministic universe also from what we
can tell the university isn't totally
deterministic so I don't really think we
have a problem right what we effectively
have is a situation where we say we
can't formally rule out the
deterministic universe we have some
evidence that suggests the university
isn't totally deterministic the evidence
is not totally bomb-proof but it's
certainly suggestive and if this isn't
totally deterministic universe the cost
of having gotten that one wrong the word
cost doesn't even mean anything cost
wrong none of these things mean anything
because it's all a nose here but that
move that's the move that I don't
understand because whether it's
inevitable or not and again I'm not
taking a piss a strong position on
determinism here I mean you know there
may be an element of randomness
just woven into the fabric of a fabric
of reality but I don't see how it
undermines any of the other distinctions
we want to make in a local frame right
there's still the difference between
having your hand stuck in on a hot plate
and not right there's still the
difference it may be mirrored
determinism to have had that experience
to have recoiled from the experience and
to now for the rest of your life have a
strong preference for not having that
happen again and in some worlds you can
avoid it again through just we're just
talking about what the billiard billiard
balls do in the end but they're still in
describing the the the anytime point in
that apparent process you can still make
all the distinctions you want to make
you can still talk about crocodiles you
can still talk about billiard balls yay
a crocodile is a very complicated
billiard ball I don't know what can even
means in the context of it I mean we're
gonna get stuck here again I'm not
saying a completely deterministic
universe is impossible what I am saying
is that the idea of talk makes no sense
it doesn't mean it wouldn't be but it
makes no sense the idea of an argument
the idea of a word
these are just simply billiard balls
bouncing off of rails and changing their
trajectory do you solid it do you feel
this when you watch a movie and you see
the characters on screen have a
conversation and have their various
adventures fall in love fall out of love
you know the movies done it's already
been shot right there's there's zero
degrees of freedom with respect to what
you're going to see in the next scene
yep
right but you haven't seen this movie
yet right right do you does the the
pointlessness of it all or the or the
the fact that it's it's not even a
happening on some level does that
continually intrude and make it seem
like this is like we can't even can't
talk about what happened in the movie
because well nothing in fact happened is
it so that's a good question and I'm
going to take it seriously I have two
different answers one is what's really
going on in the case of a movie is some
artistic presence a person or several
people have created scenarios and for
whatever reason I've decided that I want
those scenarios to play out in my mind
so that I can vicariously experience or
witness or enjoy or whatever it is and
so what I'm allowing to do is I'm
allowing this deterministic piece of
footage spliced together to create an
impression I am granting it access to
parts of my brain and then presumably
inside my brain I am temporarily
erecting a little world that contains
these characters I'm allowing them to
have identities I'm allowing them to
interact as they have been scripted in
front of me as if I was sitting at a
cafe and watching them interact and I am
at no point delusional about where I am
whether these things are real whether
those are actors or the real people so
I'm simultaneously aware that the movie
itself is completely deterministic
already scripted at the point I sit down
it's already over hmm
but what it does is it feeds data into
my mind that allows the story to unfold
in real time in a coherent fashion I see
no contradiction between those two
things on the other hand I am sometimes
aware that when I watch such a narrative
I'm sometimes aware for example of how
far I am from the end of it and
therefore what plot twists are now off
the table right if I know there's only
four minutes left in the thing there are
certain plot devices that would not be
useful and so I cannot help myself but
to know that those things won't happen
or if a character that I think is
economically very important to the
franchise has been lost there's a part
of me that thinks you know they probably
wouldn't kill that character off so
quickly and then something like Game of
Thrones takes that assumption and uses
it against you by killing off important
characters which you don't see coming
yeah but anyway yeah so I I don't know
how well that answers your question well
I'm just isn't your moment to moment
experience of your life compatible with
this experience of watching a movie so
that like I say it's like it's like in a
movie we're still talking you wouldn't
say of a movie you can't talk about the
characters you can't talk about the
people you can't talk about events
because however you look at it there's
nothing there the experience is just
light on a wall there's nothing's even
moving we're talking about still frames
that are that are moving at 24 frames a
second or we're just talking about
pixels or what I so all of that is
deflationary right there's no there's no
there there and conceptually there's no
there's zero degrees of freedom because
it's you know the the the last scene
exists just as much as the first scene
there's actually no causal properties
displayed between apparent events
because
again it's all scripted right so it's
not like an any one thing caused
everything's been arranged to seem like
it was causing each subsequent thing but
it was everything was put in place it's
a still life as Hawes was a studio and
artists and business interests the cause
was not what unfolds on the wall yeah
and so yeah but the experience of
watching a movie is compatible with
making all of the distinctions we want
to make about human events and
conversations and motives and how things
looked and felt and the emotions
displayed and when is certainly when
it's working
you're so taken in by the illusion of it
that it seems not only like real life it
seems more real than real life in some
sense because you're you're able your
relationship to it is such that you can
in in some strange way you can get
closer to the drama of human events then
you can ever afford to do in real life
when you're being seen by the other
people in the room right so that's
what's I mean the vote the pure
voyeurism of watching a movie is what
what's so seductive about it but I'm
struck by the fact that real life you
know this conversation is totally
compatible with zero degrees of freedom
in its unfolding no it's formally
compatible
well it's we cannot prove that that's
not what's going on but it's also but
but it's it's phenomenologically as the
experience of it is compatible with it
it's like I don't even think it is but I
can't formally rule it out that's what I
would say so let me let me try it let me
try this on a different way someplace I
think it's closer to home for you based
on the examples you use in your your
books there's a cemetery near my house
my kids and my wife and I ride through
it with some regularity on our bikes and
electric unicycles and stuff one day my
wife and I were biking back through it
and I was shocked in general you don't
see any
funereal activity but there was a
funeral in process two people clearly
parents burying a tiny casket carrying
pall bearers of this tiny casket on this
hill and it shocked me a little bit
there was something so much of the story
was obvious from what I was seeing
I couldn't nail it down a hundred
percent but it was like one frame was
sufficient yeah it's it reminds me of
the there was a contest for one one
sentence novels yeah I think an example
is like baby shoes for sale unworn or
something like that yeah yeah I think
it's a Hemingway actually is baby shoes
for sale never used or something yeah in
fact a friend of mine has run a contest
for six-word stories in his magazine but
anyway some days later I went back to
look at what was going on on that hill
because other night Heather had not seen
the same thing and so I wanted to figure
out what I had seen so that we could at
least understand it and it turned out
that entire Hill was dedicated to very
young children stillborn children and
the reason I raise it here is that in a
completely deterministic universe what
the hell is going on with that hell can
you imagine a completely deterministic
universe in which babies are created it
brought all the way to the point of
birth or shortly thereafter only to
torture their parents with their loss
and put their parents through the
agonizing decision to either treat this
as the death of
a human or two fail to treat it that way
I mean that Hill to me makes no
philosophical sense in a deterministic
universe in a non deterministic universe
that Hill is a tragedy but I understand
it well no because I mean it's it's just
as perverse to imagine that there's
chance in that it's I mean the only
thing as perverse as mere clockwork is
just disparities and good and bad luck
right if it's just luck that spells the
difference between having a happy long
and happy life you know with with you
know surrounded by loving friends and
family and colleagues and being in a
14-inch casket right that doesn't that
doesn't redeem that doesn't reclaim our
our sense of the way things should be oh
it doesn't reclaim any goodness it's
still why as I say it's a tragedy but
its meaning is radically altered the
idea that those children might have
grown into adults that was at least a
possibility it was on the menu of
possibilities and something went wrong
but but if that something that went
wrong was the the flap of a butterfly's
wings a continent away right again as a
bad analogy because now I'm invoking
chaos and chaos as deterministic but if
if it's a pure dice roll somewhere in
the ether that is causing the difference
rather than mere determinism then it
just seems to me it's just as morally
again nothing turns on this because
whether or not reality is morally
inscrutable or unfathomable you know
this is nowhere written that it wouldn't
be so right I mean we just
we're just now talking about our
preferences no but I guess what I'm
getting at is first so I can put myself
easily in the position of parents in the
two scenarios here parents of a child
who might have lived but didn't and
parents of a child who was never going
to live because that was written since
the beginning of the universe right I'm
very angry at that second scenario that
first scenario fills me with sorrow but
I don't have anyone to be angry about
bad luck exists and it sucks when it
afflicts you but it's not the same cruel
joke as a universe that decided to award
a child to you and then rob you of it
without accept in that universe you
don't have any illusion that you could
have or should have more importantly
done something differently well there's
no question that there's a burden along
with the universe in which multiple
things can happen that when things go
wrong you got to ask what role you
played in it there's no no question
about that well you do have to ask it in
a deterministic one it's just that it's
at a different level it's like your
bender it's a descriptive it's a
descriptive question about what happened
right like you know did this bad thing
happen because I'm the sort of person
who is you know negligent or drives
drunk or something right and yet there's
no place to stand where there's no place
to really stand where that wasn't going
to happen given the way the universe was
at yes but I don't know what you mean by
ask I mean even a word like ask seems to
me ridiculous in the context where it is
just another billiard ball ricocheting
off just another rail the issue though
is that is that randomness doesn't
reclaim what people the the meaning that
people think they're going to lose here
it doesn't recover it but it is
necessary to recovering it it is not
sufficient but it is necessary that
would be my point if there's no
randomness you can't recover it if there
is randomness you might not recover it
but at least the possibility exists
well it's just well yeah I don't really
see that I mean again I don't see I
don't see the emotional stakes here or
the psychological stakes quite the way
you do they I see because that there's
there's a significant consequence I mean
really the only parameter that that is
of consequence here is the fact that we
don't know what's going to happen next
right whatever whatever the nature of
causality is whether the universe is
split in in every instant and we're we
don't know which one we're going to be
in whether it's all being pushed behind
and it's it's all being pushed from
behind determinate deterministically and
we're just billiard balls or whether
there's a dice roller in the clockwork
the fact that the next moment in time is
always of the it's always possible just
to surprise us right if we have we have
a model with a forward-looking model of
what's likely to happen and again our
notion of likely carries with it this
this intuition that that there there are
degrees of freedom you know there's
there's possibility as a thing right but
there is in fact at the end of the day
simply whatever happened right we only
take one path through this this
landscape and we never check the
counterfactual we have a story we're
telling ourselves about the
counterfactual but again it's it's in
every moment it's it's justice stories
confirm ibly just a story right and
there's simply what happens and what
happens has this element of this
continuous element of surprise and
what's more it has the our choices are
apparent choices are in fact the
proximate cause the apparent proximate
cause of so much that matters to us
right so my choice to eat the the ice
cream is that is the thing that ended my
diet at
moment right like I could have been the
guy who stayed on the diet but I wasn't
yet again right so and then a month from
now after I've gone to you know Chaco
willing boot camp and I have a different
orientation toward discipline and
everything else now I'm the guy who's
cleared out all the ice cream in the
house now now I'm the guy who's on the
diet and lo and behold I'm losing weight
and you know in terms it turns out that
my body functions the way anybody does
and and physics matters again there's no
free will intruding here but I'm having
what I'm having this very different
experience and it's it's always
intelligible and compatible with our
ordinary intuitions about choice and
probability given the fact that we don't
know what's gonna happen next right and
that would that would be true in a fully
in a fully clockwork deterministic
universe I you know you don't you don't
know what you're gonna think next right
and I don't know what you're gonna think
next and we're both gonna hear what you
say next well again my objection here is
philosophical I can't know if I'm gonna
to completed completely deterministic
universe all I can know is that none of
the things that I think I know make any
sense in the way I think I know them
even the idea of knowing that makes no
sense
well that they wouldn't make any sense
if you could experience the universe
from that point of view right they would
make sense given that you apparently can
only experience the universe from this
point of view so look can we agree that
if the universe were some aliens
screensaver that they could have rigged
it in a completely deterministic fashion
and that it could have all of the
creatures that I know and love in it and
I could be a character and you could be
a character and we could be as
determined as the characters in a in a
film that there's nothing against the
law of physics that prevents that other
than I would argue that the outer
universe has to not be deterministic in
order for that to have come to be but
let's be agnostic about that point yeah
well no but I was making a slightly
different point which is that the the
rolls on the hill for young kids in any
one of these universes carries the same
tragedy and can be parsed from the same
set of psychological intuitions in any
of these universes simply because we as
parents or they as parents never knew
what was gonna happen next
couldn't know what was gonna happen next
all right so it's like we're just we're
at this point in the movie whether this
is really a movie or or it's really or
the stakes are really real right whether
this the movies already been shot or
we're shooting it now right this is a
this is actually that this is this is a
probably better use of the analogy
there's the imagine a documentary right
where what's being filmed is not
scripted it's really being shut you know
so it's it's real life you know on film
right so the question is are we are we
shooting this now or has this already
been shot on some level that different
yeah and from the point of view of from
the point of view of everyone who
doesn't know what's going to happen next
right the fact that it might be possible
to know what's gonna happen next or what
what you know to see the the last scene
before you see the first scene well okay
that's philosophically interesting to
entertain right and let's get the
physicists to work on on the problem of
whether or not that's so but
subjectively and in the space in which
we try to make meaning out of our lives
the thing that matters is we don't know
what's going to happen next and at each
point along the way we have to act right
we have this apparent burden of deciding
what to have for lunch right and we we
go left or right by turns and
the process is subjectively inscrutable
and and it's bound to be so and that's
the space in which we make our lives and
so and I don't see how determinism
randomness some combination thereof ever
changes the the maybe unless it changes
that moment to moment reality where you
know one philosophical truth being so
gives you a different picture of the
future essentially I don't see I don't
see how it matters I mean it's it's it's
bizarre it's bizarre to think that the
big picture is bizarre to think about
whatever is true I mean III think I I
think I feel that randomness is is
stranger than you you think it is but so
I'm so the the comparison between
determinism and randomness you know or
determinism plus randomness doesn't
isn't as invidious in my brain as it is
in yours because I both are just yeah
I've been possible to think about but we
have this we have this moment right and
then things keep appearing and among
those things are thoughts intentions
desires preferences and it's on the
basis of this roiling ocean of
phenomenology that we make our lives
right and so and no one who has a kid
knows what that kid will be like as an
adult or whether he or she will reach
adulthood right that's that's just that
that is built into the circumstance and
any any story we tell ourselves about
what was going to happen what was bound
to happen
however much we could convince ourselves
that one or the other of those stories
is true it doesn't change the fact that
we had to act under uncertainty in every
in every moment and still do well you
know I I don't know if I'm the only
person who doesn't get this point or I'm
the only person who does get this merit
but I have the sense that none of the
words that you are saying that we still
we have to act in the moment I that
those things lose all actual meaning not
that you wouldn't be saying them and not
that I wouldn't be hearing them and that
we wouldn't be you know there's no
choice about any of it but they lose all
actual meaning up in many different
frames I mean they lose meaning again
just if you're gonna use the periodic
table as well as your frame they don't
lose meaning the fact is humans evolved
they evolved to use language with each
other to exchange abstract ideas across
open space so that they could reside in
multiple brains simultaneously and their
implications could be discussed well no
there's there's no but you're smuggling
purpose into the air which need not
exist and there's the fact that this is
all happening but we didn't do this so
that we could do this
we didn't it's not intentional but
evolution built our capacity to exchange
abstract ideas across open space for a
reason which is that it gave us
competitive advantage over creatures
that had less of that ability okay but
that's a different reason that's not a
there's no teleology in this system this
is this can still be pushed from behind
it's just it's effectively this is this
this works
like there's a survivor bias here it was
a massive surveillance bias to provide
advantage in a universe in which
advantage appears to make a difference
between success and failure which to me
requires that some other outcome was
possible were it not for the capacities
in question that's yeah I mean I I don't
see that again now we're sort of going
around the same track here but I don't
see the necessity of supposing that I
mean I think that may in fact be true
right I mean possibility you know that
stands a very good chance of being a
real thing right but it's interesting to
consider how reality how you'd expect
- look if it weren't a thing yeah if
there's simply just what happened I
would expect it to work the same way but
if I could stand outside of it I would
say that's a ridiculously cruel joke
okay and yeah you know if this is let's
say that this is a deterministic
universe and that some parents somewhere
can't help but listen in to this podcast
and then they lose a child and they end
up burying the child on that hill and
they end up thinking you mean that child
was only ever a cruel joke that that
that child was never there was no
possibility of it becoming a person I
would think that person standing on that
hill would have a right to be resentful
of a universe in which that was the only
option in a way bad luck okay but there
so it may why why cash in your chips
there I mean there's so there's so many
other reasons to be resentful of a
universe even if you think there are
degrees of this universe even if you
think there are massive degrees of
freedom and there's there are different
ways to interpret even that moment I
mean like a cruel joke is just one
provincial framing to put on the nature
of reality that when when a million are
available let's write let's try another
one that I think maybe hits more
squarely on the head hmm you use in I
think the moral landscape maybe not sure
one of your books you use the example of
locked-in syndrome mmm-hmm this is a
situation in which somebody's conscious
mind is awake and functioning normally
but they are left with no power to
communicate with the outside world or
act in any way they can't raise a limb
or anything like that truly one of the
most frightening things that could
happen you have a person especially in
light of the fact that the outside world
might be unaware that that is what has
happened to you yeah and in previous
periods in history would have certainly
been aware but it certainly would have
been unaware that that was what was
happening to you yeah absolutely
as terrifying as it gets yeah I believe
that we are all in some
since in that syndrome if we are in a
completely deterministic universe and
yet have something that functions as a
consciousness if we are absolutely
trapped on a trajectory and there is no
hope of in any way deviating it we our
conscious Minds trapped as conscious
minds on trajectories in which
consciousness has essentially no meaning
other than yeah but the thing is we
don't know how good the movie is going
to get right we're the movie right and
it's and it could already be shot but we
the final scene could just be the the
the most spectacular firework display
you could be could be could not only be
stranger than we imagine it could be
stranger than we can't imagine right
that that seems to me
and I know you know you're you're none
of these things but it seems to me
solipsistic and hedonistic and no no you
forget about it's not mere pleasure
it just it could be you know just just
inscribe your deepest creative values in
the space provided but just without the
freedom to do otherwise right but then
whatever it is having been scripted
since the beginning of the movie is not
a consequence of anything to which I
might ascribe cause it just simply
happens and so my delight at the fact
that I don't know what's going to happen
and would like to know is it's simply
about somatic experience over which
there's no possibility that it could
ever have been other I mean I again I
just I think every word here loses its
meaning well it's it's not it's not just
ematic experience it's the life of the
mind as well right it's just whatever
you you know I see us as functioning in
a a landscape of mind where we don't
know what experiences are possible yeah
right we know we know that we know the
ones we've had and we can
we can form intuitions about what should
be adjacent to us in mental space right
and what might be available to more
insightful or more intelligent or
longer-lived
minds than our own right we can't we can
form we can you know get our science
fiction writers to tell us good stories
about what might be possible we can
arrange our our own nervous systems but
by various methods you know which again
of which are relate to your example of
you know pursuing some you know chaos
producing you know algorithm where we
decide to take vacations you know I have
to roll the dice and then see what
happens we can as you said we can take
psychedelics we can we can practice
meditation we can confront you know
collide with other cultures who have you
know very different norms than we do and
just see what see what that moves around
in our minds but you know you can go to
Burning Man and and be surprised by
things you find there and the net result
of all of that is pushing into again
this could all be just dominoes falling
right but and I don't see how adding
randomness to that fundamentally changes
the picture let's say it's let's say
it's just dominoes plus the the wind
gusts of randomness we're pushing into a
space that we know must exist in
potential you know it's like whether you
know whether at the end of the day there
is simply what happens there's this
apparent sense that there are all kinds
of there's an infinite number of things
that that could conceivably happen from
this point from the from the point of
view of the present and we don't know
which of those things will in fact you
know undergo the the formality of
actually becoming so and so that is a
path that is a a path of
psychological discovery whether or not
freedom is real right he's like your
your you're pushing your your in the
woods and you don't know what's in there
with you and you're exploring right that
is a psychologically a thrilling and
scary and beautiful experience and it
doesn't matter if it's a screensaver
well I I think I understand what you're
saying but here's what I feel like it
implies I feel like you and actually
other people who I've encountered who
have made a an argument for full
determinism I feel like the model is
that the world is fully deterministic up
to the border of psychology and that
you're actually able to observe and of
course everybody who would make an
argument in favor of full determinism
understands that there's nothing in
observation that is absent from the full
deterministic model but I feel like the
things that you say relative to meaning
observation doesn't matter if it's a
screensaver because it's still beautiful
and fascinating to you that all of that
more or less assumes a mind that is
independent of complete determinism
trapped in a world that is completely
deterministic so that the the human
being it has no meaningful ability to
deviate anything but it's still
functioning in a way that you can
appreciate it
whereas I would say the word appreciate
has zero meaning you know it is well
know that the know the the appreciation
is still mere mechanism in your mattress
but it feels a certain way right so and
like I didn't I didn't author my
preference for beauty over ugliness
right but finding that I have one
becomes actionable right again and to
the degree to which I'm moved by it or
if it flips tomorrow is against
something I can't account for but
there's still this experience of being
suddenly presented
with something that you didn't see a
moment ago and finding it beautiful and
there's no place you don't have to
justify that from you don't have to
stand outside of that mechanism to
justify it to make it actionable you
just it's just it's just there right
it's just a lock and key that that you
keep you know marrying and twisting
again and again and they change but in
this picture you're describing a
circumstance in which the mechanism is
acting through means that are utterly
bizarre if they don't mean what they
appear to me so the fact that I am
speaking to you by vibrating the air
molecules between us in such a way that
they vibrate a membrane in the side of
your head which then causes hairs in a
canal to flop over such that you can
deduce the abstract meaning in my mind
and build a version of it in your own
mind that's such an odd way if I say hey
pass the salt and I'm doing this through
this utterly magical mechanism of
vibrating air molecules between you and
me hmm
right and the purpose is to get the salt
from your side of the table to my side
of the table what a mundane thing to
happen in a universe by such an odd
means why am I able to put an abstract
thought into your mind from across the
room no no no one ever said this wasn't
strange it's everything is strange no I
think it's like a posture I think it's
like saying that a baseline but guess
what you measure it more closely but I
mean this is this is the joke you know
people say life is strange but you know
I say compared to what I don't know who
this is Randy Newman or somebody but the
what are you comparing it to like this
is everything looked at closely
disgorges it's utter strangeness let's
put it this way I do believe in
parsimony and so my point is not that it
isn't all very very strange because it
is my point is
we ought to minimize the necessity of
strangeness to our explanations as much
as possible because as we allow
ourselves strangeness in our
foundational claims our thinking
devolves into madness well no I think
that made strangeness I think it's just
it's in eradicable in just in every case
it's not that I mean is it's there's a
fundamental strangeness to the fact that
anything exists right however it exists
whether lawfully or randomly there's I
mean administer this is this is where
like if you look closely enough at
what's happening or what seems to be
happening then ideas that sound like
they add a whopping dose of strangeness
to the picture don't actually add much
at all so like the idea that this might
be a simulation right well is that
really much stranger than what seems to
be going on when you actually it's it's
it's more and it's it's not parcel I'll
grant you it's not parsimonious or at
least you know not you know absent so
you know taking a certain argument
seriously it's not parsimonious but it's
I mean everything that everything that
we think is happening is so bizarre that
it's it's a and and our engagement with
it is so bizarre I mean this is this is
I don't know if you've followed Donald
Hoffman's work at all but he's a I'm a
cognitive psychologist who you know has
this kind of user interface theory of
consciousness and and I will have I
think before this comes out I will have
just released a podcast with him where
I'm on ik and I interviewed him and you
know his argument you know the TED talk
version of his argument is that
we what we think of as our engagement
with reality you know our conscious
perception of reality is like is is very
much analogous to a a user interface
like on a desktop of a computer and you
know you know the the trash bin or the
blue folder icon is there's really no
relationship to what is in fact true at
the base layer of reality and it's just
it's useful to think about these things
but you know the blue pixels of the
folder do not in any way represent
what's actually going on you know at the
base layer of code and we are and he has
a dart don't win an argument about why
this would be so but it's not it's not
just that we are not totally in touch
with reality as it is we are basically
not remotely in touch with reality as it
is and we have a we're we're in a
simulacrum of something which is you
know it is as strange as if it were a
simulation well to me on the one hand
this seems like it has to be almost
uncontroversial that we are sensitive to
certain stimuli and completely
insensitive to others means that what we
experience as reality is the dimmest
edit that allows you to maneuver without
tripping over stuff and injuring
yourself and you know that we have
enough information to improve our odds
substantially of getting through the
world but we don't have anything like
the ability to observe the world
directly so some of it may be I'm not
getting it yeah he's like I mean he has
a just a stronger claim built into it
which is that you know when you do the
the game theoretic analysis of the
fitness functions fitness since Fitness
is the only actual signal in in
Darwinian terms and truth isn't a signal
at all Fitness it being in touch with
reality is just that the probability of
being in touch with the reality at all
essentially goes to goes to zero in
competition with Fitness over enough
interation iterations of gameplay so
this is a good place to maybe shift
topics slightly um but that does seem to
me like another way of speaking about
metaphorical truth that and in fact I
got into this in a recent podcast with
Jim rut where my argument was that color
is in effect a sort of useful fiction
it's not that the wavelengths aren't
real but are categorizing them and
painting our world our internal world
with them in order to figure out where
one object starts and another stops that
that is a highly useful falsehood
deployed in the interest of our fitness
and that in fact that's the point
sometimes the truth helps us with
respect to fitness but where the two
diverge you should expect Fitness to
dominate and that that's true
perceptually and it's true cognitively
and in every other we're assuming
evolution is is the explanation yeah I
mean his argument is that truth is just
never a variable I mean it always washes
out but it's you know I didn't take that
part of the conversation with him very
far it makes sense to me if I mean that
the the intuition is well you need to be
more or less in touch with whatever
reality at large is because that would
be that has to be adaptive right because
you're in relationship to this thing so
and so it's is so again it would be a
kind of a bad edit of reality but still
some some truth must be getting in he's
got a more fundamental claim about truth
at the end of the day just not getting
in right we have what we have is a
fitness landscape that is select we have
we have built a you evolution that's
built as a user interface that need have
no relationship to reality outside the
interface
apart from conserving fitness and once
you once you run those numbers you get
you get conjugal in his framework
conscious agents that have no truth
value at all to their their beliefs and
and you know they're you know the icons
on the desktop all they have is you know
Fitness you know Fitness within their
within their regime and anyway it's it's
interesting my intuitions have kind of
slowly migrated in that direction at
least finding that somewhat you know
plausible if not convincing but it's
just we you know we don't know I mean
this is just comes back to the the JBS
Haldane quote which I've mangled a few
times here which is the the idea that
reality is not only stranger than we
suppose is stranger than we can suppose
clearer yak we're very clear does yeah
yeah the British version and that is you
know just based on Darwinian principles
that shouldn't be surprising to us
there's no reason why we EV Aleutian
would have given us intuitions properly
formed so as to take the measure of how
strange reality might seem in the end
I'm gonna disagree with that slightly I
mean I I basically agree and I have said
elsewhere that you are not built to be
right you're built to be effective and
that those two depart from each other
but they don't always depart from each
other and I would argue that actually
there's a temporal phenomenon where
sometimes you're useful fictions are
much less useful and that it makes sense
to step in the direction of an
interaction with reality that's more
informative in order for you to alter
what you think and therefore what you do
in a way that enhances fitness and so I
would argue that our capacity to do this
is adaptive and what it means is that
our relationship to reality is
arbitrary nor does it exist at a
constant strength but it shifts based on
where we are in in history mm-hmm
so anyway it's a sort of middle ground
position I guess but but I do think it's
interesting how all of these discussions
when you push them far enough turn into
relatives of each other so you know the
freewill discussion has treaded very
close to the religious discussion that
we've been involved in in various places
and maybe it would make some sense to to
visit that before we finish this up can
I return you to a moment in the debate
between you and Jordan Peterson where I
was moderating in Vancouver there's a
moment late on what must have been day
one in which you leveled a challenge to
Jordan about why a God as he sees that
entity would give a damn about whether
or not you masturbated or would be in
any way responsive to prayers that you
might offer and it was a tough spot for
me because at that moment I felt like
there was a lot to be done between you
and me but it wasn't my debate with you
there you were there to talk to Jordan
and I was there to keep you guys on
track which actually I should just thank
you it was an honor to be invited to do
that
yeah likewise you you were great there
but my question is I think that in that
moment I offered some pushback as much
as I could manage given the context and
said look actually there's a very good
reason that a metaphorical God should
have an opinion on whether or not you
should masturbate and I didn't get
around to saying I also think there's a
mechanism by which prayers do not
require a supernatural entity for them
to be sensible in a in a Darwinian sense
of the term and I I remember our
interaction I thought I saw a light bulb
go on over your
head as you got pushback from me on that
topic do you remember the net no I don't
remember it so I'd have to queue up the
video or we can play it play out the
movie in real time here well the the
pushback I gave you got lost because of
course masturbation is so funny that you
know there's just no way the
conversation was going to endure the
question but the pushback was look
obviously masturbation interfaces with
motivation about sex and motivation
about sex has everything to do with
fitness and so doesn't it make a great
deal of sense that should these
religious beliefs be literally false
metaphorically true statements that a
deity described in such statements would
actually prefer that you not masturbate
such a innovated to reproduce oh yeah
yeah no no that I totally accept that I
think what I wouldn't have accepted
there is that Jordan I mean I wouldn't
be talking about a metaphorical God
because I don't think Jordan was talking
about a metaphorical God and they say if
you were just talking about the the
possible pragmatism of certain doctrines
that have been traditionally anchored to
what we have every reason to believe
that our false beliefs about deities
well then yeah I mean that's a rationale
that that makes total sense to me okay
so what I didn't get around to was the
the point about prayer so let's take the
classic the classic prayer of the the
person kneeling by the side of their bed
before going to sleep person kneeling by
the side of the bed before they go to
sleep is very likely to focus on things
that are possible and desirable or
likely and undesirable and to be asking
their deity to intervene in the
likelihood of these things you know
please help Uncle Jim get better or
you know please help me perform well
tomorrow and the recital or whatever it
is it's interesting that that comes
right before the conscious mind goes
offline and the brain as a whole remains
active and engaged in scenario building
and other sorts of activities my
contention and I can't prove this
although my guess is somebody has proved
it is that your thought process
immediately before going to bed has a
strong influence over the content of the
dreams that you have and those dreams
seem prone to explore problems in your
world now it might be that you asked
your deity to intervene on things where
your ability to use your brain to find a
solution is meaningless you know if you
ask the deity to intervene in Uncle
Jim's cancer your prayer is unlikely to
be answered on the other hand if you're
praying to not screw up that one move in
the recital tomorrow then it's possible
that you end up running through the
various things that trip you up and when
you get to the recital actually you're
more practice than you realize your
prayer might be answered right well I
think there are many reasons why prayer
might be good for something that don't
entail a God actually listening and that
that's just one by me that's I think
it's it's a little I mean obviously most
prayer is not necessarily paired with
sleep right and maybe the prayer prayer
is a tool or as an injunction is not you
know you know our you know sort of
cartoon picture of what it must be like
to be religious we picture people
praying before they go to sleep but in
you know just theologically prayer as a
mechanism isn't you know yeah
I'm unaware of anyone recommending that
you do it at the end of the day as
opposed to you know whenever the fancy
strikes or well you know
in the morning when you go to when you
go to church or what it so it's like
there's there's some you can do it at
any time of day and there are many
reasons why it could have good
consequences for you I mean one kind of
more basic reason that has nothing to do
with you know memory or skill
consolidation that happens during REM
sleep is it is a time where you are
consciously entertaining your most
pro-social intentions with respect to
the people in your life you know and and
even just people in strangers on the
street you're praying for good outcomes
for your whole you know society or you
know tribe so it just seems like it's a
it's a good moral you know pro
cooperative algorithm to be running in
general you know just having to have
kind of drummed into you and I mean it's
just it's it's a kind of a meditation on
good intentions it is and especially in
the context you know of a character
service or something where you have
people more or less speaking on behalf
of a deity
especially when it's a deity who is
empowered to reward you or punish you
severely that you know making prayers
about pro-sociality as you put it while
in a venue that is constantly reminding
you of your concerns about falling short
of the deities expectations of you and
all of that that that is bound to
actually alter your behavior hmm in ways
that I think you and I would agree are
often positive not inherently but you
know to the extent that pro-sociality is
what's being induced
then doing so in a context where the
rewards and punishments are being you
know centered so that you are reminded
of them potentially affects your
behavior more than it would if you just
picked a random moment to do it yeah and
also just I mean I think the biggest
lever for that religion is pulling from
a Darwinian
a sense is that by appealing to an
all-seeing God who will punish you for
your transgressions you are creating a
basis for for cooperation to scale among
strangers in under conditions in which
we know that human justice is going to
be imperfect at best right so it's like
it you're if we know that everyone in
this game you know friend or stranger
believes privately that they they really
can't get away with anything that is a
is a durable durable basis of
cooperation that doesn't exist if you
think as long as no one can see me while
I'm doing this thing you know I can get
away scot-free so knowing that everyone
believes that it's a relevant difference
you know it's a highly relevant
difference and think about the other
little what I would call hacks that go
along with that that context so you know
you might be calling the priest father
right if you and somebody else are
calling the priest father that makes you
siblings I think this is not unlike
oppressed communities where people call
each other brother and sister that
you're bootstrapping a route into kin
selected modalities that I would not I'm
not arguing for group selection and you
know we don't have time today to talk
about that but there is another
mechanism but simply emphasizing the
closeness of relationship is liable to
increase the degree to which that
cooperation happens
likewise the symbols of remembrance for
those who have died being present the
belief that they are looking down and
therefore there's a sort of extra judge
of your behavior and whether you're
living up to expectations all of these
things point in the same direction of
creating an alteration and behavior that
is likely to be Fitness enhancing by
virtue of
strengthening your I'm trying to avoid
the word group since it's not what I
mean here but trying to strengthen your
your lineage or your congregation or
whatever whatever the entity is right so
okay that's all that's all good it
sounds like we're on the same page about
that I guess what I what I want to get
at do you feel that your position on
religion is in motion at all my my basic
position
I wouldn't say is just because it's
always allowed for multiple things to be
true which which seem incompatible at
first glance but you know are easily
reconciled and have always been from my
point of view so the the fact that you
can you can you know this is a point
I've always made explicitly we have to
acknowledge that religion isn't just one
thing there are many different religions
on offer and they do things differently
right they believe different things
there's different consequences to each
you know that they're obviously there
their similarities but I mean religion
is a is a very broad concept like food
right and you know not all foods are
doing the same thing and they're not you
know they're not all fit for the same
occasion and so if you can point to a
local instance where some person's life
or some communities life was obviously
made better by religion that is not
actually a a point against any argument
I've ever made right and so I've always
acknowledged that those you can find
those examples right and so too with the
flipside of that you can find atheists
doing terrible things and made miserable
by their atheism or atheists who wish
they were religious right and can't find
that thing that you know they know is
making life meaningful for their
religious brothers
sisters and they're all depressed and
nihilistic and the fact that they don't
have religion or something something
that would do the work of religion is
some part of that that problem for them
again that's not a rejoinder to anything
I've ever said I mean my my basic
argument is that whatever is good
whatever good can be found in religion
is I've yet to find an important
exception to this rule ml admit as
possible that there is an exception but
is is better found some other way right
so if you can give me a list of things
that that you know moral actions that
religion gets people to do I can find
you better reasons to do those things
right reasons that scale better that are
more durable that will not that will
survive contact with our ongoing
investigation of the way the universe is
scientifically there's nothing we're
gonna find out about our brains
that'll cancer that'll cancel these good
reasons for being moral or going to
Africa to to alleviate famine whereas
the virgin birth of Jesus is a bad
reason to do those things right even if
it gets again undeniable it gets some
number of people to do good things you
know under the ages of crazy police so
yeah I don't think so there's always
been what I perceive to be a lot of
flexibility in my view because it's you
know there again there's no you you can
point to mountains of good done
somewhere sometime for religious reasons
and its net it's never been never never
been in contradiction to what I thought
was true okay
so I want to point you to two things
where I think there might be a reason to
to open it up and check whether or not
you still feel the way you did in the
moral landscape you write that you have
been confronted with people who make the
argument that because religion is
long-standing it must therefore be
adaptive
I would make a version of this argument
I believe it to be true and it doesn't
quite have enough of the components that
the added component is that
long-standing religions that carry a
heavy cost for those who believe in them
must be adaptive they must pay back that
cost plus some in order to persist and I
think in the book if I remember
correctly you make the argument that a
basically a bad bit of code could
survive in the world in the form of
religious belief and my point would be
that becomes implausible once you're
talking about a feature of essentially
every culture historically speaking
maybe up until the present and let me
swap in two things for religion which I
think run through in the same way which
I don't think you'd be tempted to defend
by the same logic the first would be
ignorant of science ignorant of science
as a cultural universal it's been with
us for millennia Missa misapprehensions
of causality based on an unscientific
view of the world you know not knowing
anything about the germ theory of
disease must be doing some good because
it's a cultural Universal has been with
us for millennia I don't think you'd be
tempted to make that argument so that's
one so that's like the one way of do one
one thing that is religion for me is
it's a it's a it's another name we put
to to ancient ignorance willful yeah so
in the it's becoming increasingly
willful and in them you know as we get
more knowledge on board but so I don't
think you'd be tempted to make the
argument there that scientific ignorance
must be doing its work because it's so
highly conserved it's a certain point of
something we get over and we never we
don't look back on nostalgic ly but
probably a better analogy is to
witchcraft which is also a cultural
universal it's it
it's very similar to religion in certain
ways you know believing in magic spells
is a lot like believing in prayer again
ubiquitous and still survives in it's
really just a contingent fact of recent
history that it isn't as universal
currently as religion is and if you go
to Africa it's basically Universal in
Africa right so if we were living on
Planet Africa magic would be more or
less just as much of a going concern as
religion is I don't think anyone's
saying listen oh I never run into this
argument and someone must be making it
somewhere but no one is coming back at
me you know in the Jordan Peterson mode
of saying listen if you think we're
gonna get rid of witchcraft you've got
another thing coming witchcraft is so
important and Europe you know European
civilization is you know you don't get
Douglas Murray saying listen we have to
be honest with how much witchcraft is an
integral part of our you know the
civilizing impulse and the you know that
the rights of the individual how could
we how could we think about the rights
of the individual without giving
Aleister Crowley his due right and or
yarny of course we now file the New York
Times defending witchcraft and
advertising their interviews with
witches
and I front-page well so here's here's
I'm glad we did this because I think
it's possible you don't know where I am
on this topic yeah I might not I am I
will defend willful ignorance as a
product of the same process and belief
in witchcraft as a product of the same
process in none of these cases am i
defending their continued use okay so
which distinguishes you from what Jordan
was doing and that would have been doing
in that argument or I believe that my
sitting between you two was a physical
fact and metaphorically put me exactly
where I stand that I'm I am half way
between your two arguments and what that
means
is and I have to be very careful I'm
gonna get a lot of pushback on this I
know but I do believe that we have no
choice but to step back from these
metaphorical belief systems in the
present that the predicament we find
ourselves in is so dangerous and the
incompatibility of these belief systems
with each other is such an impediment to
navigating our differences that we have
to stand down literal belief in that
which can't be established for the sake
of future generations where I think we
end up in a different place is you say
well there's nothing that we do with
those belief systems that we couldn't do
better with a rational belief system and
what I would say is that that might be
true if we were fully informed
unfortunately what we are stuck with is
a situation where we can't tolerate
having mutually incompatible
metaphysical belief systems declared
off-limits from critique by virtue of
the fact that they have ancient roots we
can't deal with the problems of the
modern world in that predicament but to
turn off these mechanisms is to invite a
whole other set of dangers so while I on
balance probably agree with you that we
must step in the direction of the
rational from the point of view of at
least what I would call the common space
where we all meet this is what got me in
trouble on Twitter a couple weeks ago
was that I was essentially making an
argument that where we interact with
each other we need to be in rational
headspace and that making appeals to
these unprovable metaphorical realms is
destructive and dangerous but in
stepping away from that we don't have a
good substitute and the lack of a good
substitute means we are certain to do us
ourselves all kinds of harm even if
ultimately we might have a rational
scheme that so well understood the
dangers that it could address them what
we don't have is anything that has stood
the test of time well enough to stand in
for these metaphorical belief systems
but but nothing needs to stand in for
witchcraft right we just need to we just
need to honestly acknowledge our
knowledge such as it is
and the boundary between it and our
ignorance and the problems we're trying
to solve
so if if we if witchcraft traditionally
has applied itself to problems like crop
failure which still concern us
and it has invoked as a mechanism
something as as implausible as the evil
eye has been a socially divisive as the
evil eye because you know neighbors
murder neighbors over over this apparent
crime when crops fail and so to with you
know illness you know we don't know
where it comes from we we have a dim
sense that you know the the the old
crone across the way could be
responsible because we have reasons why
should we find her
unattractive I've never liked her yeah
and so we're gonna blame her for not
only the weather and and the result in
crop failure but you know the the death
of our kids again we're functioning in a
circumstance where our ignorance is
impressive and getting remediated by
science and just in a rational
conversation in general and it's pretty
clear that process just has to continue
now I'm not saying it's not possible to
be unhappy even while being well
informed right I mean there's more to
life than just being right or not being
wrong and that's why things like you
know meditation and you know ethical
codes and and just a larger project of
living an examined life I mean all of
that is is
is about more than just understanding
science and and you know scientists are
not even you know you know as I hang out
with scientists it's not it's not like
they advertise their the depth of their
wisdom more than other people tend to
write them so this like science science
is a discrete game that you can play or
not play but within its parameters it's
the only game in town right and it and
it and you read and unlike other games
those the it's the kind of the the
theater of its implications continues to
grow and grow in surprising ways and
grows and never diminishes right it's
not like we and this is the amidst the
challenge I I have traditionally uttered
to religious people as I get me give me
an example of one problem where we used
to have a scientific answer for which
now the answer the best answer on offer
is religious whereas and you know I
number on that list you know none come
no compelling examples that I can think
of whereas the opposite list is it's
long and only growing and the number of
things that we have for which we used to
have a religious answer you know a bad
one and now we have a scientific one and
that ground is never going to be seated
again you know I mean again take the
clear case of you know epilepsy in a
world where you don't know about
epilepsy and you think it's demonic
possession right well once you get a
signs of neurology you move from from
the the Theological prescription of
exorcism to let's get you some help at
the level of the brain and there is just
no scenario where this is going to
revert back to to the church unless we
find out something else about reality
that suddenly requires you know some
other man
that the church might be able to say oh
well that's what we were we were really
talking about like so let's just say
let's take this further and let's say
that well it turns out that you know
prayer just that use of attention is so
efficacious for certain people in
certain ways that and now we understand
it you know by reference to the placebo
effect or you know some something that
that you know at some point of kind of
offer some point of contact with a
science of the mind that you know here
is what it's good for right you know
that's not what the people people were
that you know recommending in in the
year 1300 you know in the capitals of
Europe when they were burning witches
right the who didn't exist but maybe
there's some remnant from religion that
we can prop up at the end of the day and
say okay this is this is important or
maybe there's some remnant that is
actually you know theologically you know
seemingly grandiose like the sorts of
things we were talking about earlier
like if we are a screensaver you know we
are God's screensaver whatever that may
be God is not the sort of God who is the
the neurotic who can care about you know
whether you've sacrificed a goat or a
ram or you know on what day or you know
I mean none of the Iron Age
prescriptions map on to that but it's
close enough it's so strange right if in
fact we have been you know created by an
alien intelligence and on in some other
context that it would be open to the
religious people of the 22nd century to
say well that clearly that's what the
Bible must've been getting at right
you know worthy or an alien screensaver
that's that's what is you you you know
that's the logos right you know that's
the okay fine but that's again that's
not that's not actually the code anyone
was running you know oh that long ago
right and
it remains to be seen what reality is at
large insofar as we can interact with it
and the process that will get us a
better and better picture of that is
never to go back and say listen
witchcraft has been with us for so long
we we tinker with it at our peril
we need this you know this pop Aryan
process of critique to continue on all
fronts it needs to happen in science
because that is what that's what science
is right but it needs to have the
boundary that has to get broken down is
the taboo around doing this on other
fronts we need to do this to religion
and the reason why that's so
uncomfortable for so many people is
because religion doesn't survive those
tests well at all right okay and so much
of religion is predicated on a
fundamentally different orientation the
orientation of faith right I'll tell you
what you do with your doubts you silence
them not by the not by a successful
process of critique toward better
explanations you silence them because
you're gonna burn in hell for [__]
ever if you don't write whether you
believe me or not that's the proposition
that 99.9% of people have been
confronted with in human history under
the you know the ages of we know one or
another religion and that's the thing
we're still trying to recover from it
and I don't see any reason to be
sentimental about that oh I'm not being
sentimental I'm just simply pointing out
we're damned if we do and damned if we
don't
and I believe our problems are so novel
that this isn't even a close call
anymore but to your point about
witchcraft not hard for me to come up
with an evolutionary explanation that's
plausible enough for why the crop
failure example results in demonizing
people and what role that plays there's
no part of me that wishes to defend this
practice but to understand why it might
evolved is a different matter rep is it
but why have any more respect for Iron
Age religion why have any more respect
for Iron Age religion first I'm not sure
why you go back to the Iron Age I
believe we are talking about well if
you're gonna be Abrahamic about it or at
least with respect to Judaism and
Christianity or you're more or less
there mm-hmm because I'm not sure that
that's exactly what we're doing we're
talking about why tread carefully around
structures whose roots go back to the
Iron Age well no but specific beliefs
yes and like that I mean that the the
crucial thing for me with respect to any
of these religions as a thing that the
only thing that an atheist needs to do
to win the argument is to point out that
there's no reason to believe that any of
these books are anything other than
books right it's it's a textual claim
again just now we're talking about
Judaism Christianity and Islam sure the
moment you deal with the books the
moment you say there's these books do
not bear the slightest sign of
omniscient author's authorship we know
too much about how they were authored
the reason is there's nothing to do with
the supernatural yeah and what's more if
you just think of how good a book would
would be if it were the product of
omniscience you know it just it it made
it just beggars belief that anyone
imagines these books were the the
product of omniscience so the moment you
do that you have destroyed these
religions there that it is it's an
unrecoverable error to to I mean it is
the thing it is the point passed which
no self-respecting I mean remand Judaism
is a slight tweak on this because you
know that most Jews have lost their
religion and just don't want to admit it
but the the the moment you get past this
textual claim
and you just reduce these to be in books
like any other books susceptible to to
criticism like any other books and then
your this is a quick step to admitting
that they're not even especially good
books on very important topics most of
the time right and so then you're then
your left finding these you know
diamonds in the dunghill that are still
diamonds I mean the the you know the
Golden Rule is fantastic wherever you
find it and if you find it in in the New
Testament great but it is utterly
seditious concession to force upon
religious people that these are just
books written by human beings well but
they're not they're not just books well
no but it's nor are the books of
Shakespeare and in or the plays of
Shakespeare no experience as far as I
know knows of it and know of it and
Homer they're all they're all throw out
pregnant with with metaphor and and you
know life application that's what that's
not what renders them on the book like
what renders them unbook like is the
process of evolution of what is the
content in other words you have many of
these have been set in stone and
resisted evolution right and so the more
set in stone they are the more likely
you are to have basically mimetic
hitchhikers traveling along with the I
don't mean good necessarily but the
Fitness enhancing wisdom inside of the
things you you'll get hitchhikers if the
whole thing is frozen in a state on the
other hand if you have something let's
take Christianity for example
Christianity you have lots of debate
within Christendom about what to believe
and how to apply it and what its
implications are and all of that and
those sectarian differences are the
mimetic diversity upon which selection
acts so what we find are populations who
have a sacred canon that has been
compared to competitors and found
effective I'm trying not to use
normative terms because I don't believe
the normative terms are inherently
warranted but again what I really want
us to understand about each other is
that we are not in the relationship that
you typically have with your detractors
who say some of the things that I'm
saying I believe that we do have to step
in the direction that you're talking
about but that the danger of doing so is
actually more substantial than than you
or most people give it credit for so
ironically I think the danger is
magnified by this meme that it is
dangerous to will let go of these
traditional structures because what that
what that prevents is an honest and
creative look at rational alternatives
right so because so many you know
otherwise secular well-educated
Christians Muslims Jews Hindus Buddhists
have spent their entire lives telling
themselves that there's no other way to
get the good stuff that we value because
reason is this you know this this dry
valueless you know calculation device
there's no alternative but to hold on to
this tradition even though we can't
justify most of it and we don't want to
be pressed on the particulars
even though 90% of what's in these books
embarrasses us we still have to hold
these books before all others and and
not think too hard about alternatives
though there will never be an
alternative to the Bible if you're a
Christian there will never be an
alternative to the Quran if you're a
Muslim there ket is unthinkable right
and because that's where we're stuck
and we've told that we've sold ourselves
this this story of risk we in fact have
made it far more difficult to come up
with truly modern you know deep value
conserving structures in our culture we
don't we don't we don't have a a wisdom
culture that we don't have a 21st
century wisdom culture we've got a a
piecemeal you know by turns 500 AD
wisdom cult 500 BC 500 you know 0-0 AD
and 500 500 AD wisdom culture or pseudo
wisdom culture brought forward into a
culture that for which wisdom isn't even
a variable right and what we need is a
truly modern scientifically rationally
sound approach to exploring in the in
this domain of all possible experience
so I so I heard you make a claim in
there that I I I just wanted to get it
on the table then we can track it your
claim was that the basically my position
that these things are ancient
compendiums of wisdom and that we are in
danger by endangered by confronting them
that that is counterproductive to the
objective of getting to a shared
rational perspective that would allow us
to move wisely forward it's not fair yep
yeah okay I actually think the opposite
we'll just imagine if we did that in
with anything else that was of
importance to us like just technology
like imagine with you know if someone's
trying to invent a
you know a way to fly to the moon and in
a world where we only have propellers
right and if what if we had this sense
that listen whatever we do it's got to
be propeller based otherwise you know we
will have we will have I mean we would
will have falsified all the sacrifices
of our ancestors yeah I get it and of
course I would never make that point I
believe I'm not even a strong
emergentist I believe the scientific
story to the extent that we can discover
it will ultimately allow us to get the
full stack in one coherent explanation
hmm we're not there yet for sure the
question really is what opens the door
and I believe and you know I'm having
one hell of an anecdotal run here but my
interaction with people of faith who are
in a position to at least listen to what
I have to say on this topic is that it
is opening a door to considering what a
rational shared worldview might be I
don't think it's opening the door very
wide but I do think the door was closed
in a sense by what religious people
perceived and sometimes was hostility
from the Atheist community that
caricatured by not acknowledging that
the religion ever had any content by
portraying it as a pathology inherently
a pathology that of course caused an
offensive right but that's not something
I mean I I've received as much defensive
nough seni one but that's not something
I've ever done I've always been in touch
with the experience that you know that
is the baby in the bath water that that
you know I think people anyone should
want to conserve and yet I've met the
same hostility and the reason several
reasons for that but one is that most
religious people aren't actually mystics
or aspiring mystics or contemplatives
they're not about becoming like Jesus or
like mr meister eckhart right or you
know st. seraphim of sarov i mean these
are not they're not that's not the game
they're playing they're terrified normal
neurotic people who are worried about
death and suffering so it was a version
of Pascal's wager and I if you'll accept
that as a label for this point I do
believe part of what we run into is that
it is potentially given the calculus
that has been divinely handed down as
far as these people are concerned it is
very dangerous to traffic in skepticism
and when a somebody comes to you
challenging the divinity of Jesus for
example it's very cheap to fight back in
fact in the calculus of getting into
heaven probably that counts for a lot
and so I do think there's a distortion
in how resistant people are and what I
think needs to happen is we need to both
sides of the conversation actually need
to move and I must say I listened
carefully to your podcast with Richard
Dawkins mm-hmm and I do have the sense
that Richard Dawkins is actually in
motion on a time scale that's hard to
see and that I think you'd you you know
you did important work with him on your
podcast and actually you can see exactly
where it is that he's hung up in this
argument where he makes the point that
he sees the competition between
religions something like he sees the
competition between species and he uses
the example of squirrels in Europe where
a new world squirrel drives a old world
squirrel to extinction upon being
introduced but in any case the slow
motion that each of us experience in our
position as we are exposed to higher
quality versions of what's on the other
side is actually I hope going to result
in us converging where we can do two
things
we can talk about why it is necessary
that we at least create a space where we
have only the rational and we are not
forced to kowtow to unprovable mystical
beliefs and the other thing is it would
be really important if religious people
would start separating between the
traditions that they hold dear and the
mechanisms that prevent those things
from being scrutinized the very pushback
that you and I have received is
turbocharged because what has made it
durable over time is a mechanism it's an
immune system that fights that which
would challenge some of those beliefs my
point is at this moment in history we
actually have to open up things that may
be needed an immune system to prevent
them from being opened up in the past
and that means religious people in some
sense have to you know turn off the
burglar alarm on those things so that we
can talk about what role they're playing
and that that's going to require their
participation well it's a thing they
naturally do to every other religion
today it's the reason why a Christian
doesn't convert to Islam tonight right
like just even just the benign neglect I
mean that's that's the way most atheists
treat religion most of the time anyway
it's not like atheism is predicated on
analyst lis criticizing religion or
trying to update it or trying to find
out what's wrong with it it's it's it's
just there's no reason to pay attention
to it because it is it's not justified
and that's exactly what every religious
person does to every other religion to
and so it's not it's it's actually just
it's asking for a coherence in the kind
of evidentiary tests you would apply to
any belief that didn't get smuggled in
with mother's milk to you
and I mean part of the frustration of it
of you know that Moe that most atheists
feel and you know I certainly feel it on
this topic is just looking at this all
in terms of opportunity costs you know
so it's almost like well like whoa
what's that what's the problem with the
trump presidency well one major problem
is just sheer opportunity cost like just
think of all the good things we're not
doing when we're talking about how bad
Trump is and trying to figure out how to
get him unelected or impeached or you
know what's it's just just reacting to
him on Twitter like like as toxic as all
that is and all the bad effects you can
easily point to forget about all that
just think of all the bandwidth concerns
it specifies a lot of processes yeah
yeah it's just it's unbelievable right
and when you look when you when you put
that lens up to the history of religion
right it is just grotesque the amount of
human creativity and ingenuity that has
that continues to be lost now again
there may be some I'm agnostic as to
whether or not there was ever a period
in human history where you might say
actually it was necessary here given
that given the tools on hand this was
not not only useful it was in some ways
optimal given we had it we had a sort of
bottleneck to get through or you know a
valley to descend into to climb out of
but like this is you know that this was
a necessary course for the species or at
least you know the the groups that have
have survived maybe that's the case but
now when you don't want to it's just
when you think of the fact that there
are kids you know being taught that
everything in the Quran is the most
important thing you could possibly you
know cognize over the course of a human
life and you know being terrified with
with thoughts of hell
lest their attention stray right or and
it's and the Mormons are doing it and
the Scientologists are doing under every
you know you know cultish or or larger
framework this is what's happening just
forget about that the the the bad
effects just just in terms of
opportunity cost it's some it's a
tragedy right and so I think every
atheist who's not spending any time on
any of those errant projects right just
it's they see they see a whole color
thing that doesn't make a lot of sense
here is that when you when you hear the
argument of a sort that you just frame
that this is you know there's real risk
here there's real we do this at our
peril you know most people most of the
time really need this stuff or have
needed this stuff people are almost
never talking about themselves and they
the conversation is always framed with
like listen I don't need this my wife
doesn't need it our kids aren't gonna
need it we're all fine
but listen you don't understand how
people really need this stuff well know
people most people are just like us if
given the chance I mean I think that's a
fair operating assumption no nobody's
kids are going to spontaneously become
[Music]
Jehovah's Witnesses but for some process
of indoctrination you know and if they
did spontaneously become Jehovah's
Witnesses that would be tantamount and
about to madness right you would say if
something has gone wrong with your mind
if you de novo believe these things
right it's only under a process of
indoctrination that you can explain the
process how the process of a healthy
human mind coming to believe those
things well I agree I just think that
the you know this is simply a belief
that I've arrived at through the
trajectory I've been on but I feel that
those of us who have
thing to say about the importance of
dealing in the rational at this point in
history and it's never been more
important would be wise to clean our
house such that we are not guilty of
falsely demonizing those on the other
side and I agree you've been quite
careful but I do think that there is a
tendency to view the functionality of
religion as the exception rather than it
having been the clear fuel of the
endeavor until modern times and that
once once we get there we're much more
here about two people who we're in the
end we need to appeal to and let them
know actually you're not under attack
but there is an important problem to be
solved and well no they they are they
will be under attack where when it
really matters I mean that's just the
thing it's like you know you're not
everyone is free to believe whatever
they want to believe until your beliefs
are really are an obstacle to some very
good important thing happening or
they're likely to cause some you know
raise our risk of something terrible
happening in the meantime so ya know you
know nothing it doesn't matter much at
all what you believe about vaccines
until we invent really important ones
you know until we have a pandemic that's
killing everyone you know and you know
it's it's not it's you know measles plus
okay I can tolerate what you think about
measles because you know not that many
people die from it it's it's just a big
hassle in the end but no when when we
have this new pandemic that is you know
got seventy five percent mortality and
it it's not it's Menino pretense of
being polite in the face of these
beliefs it'll be a moral emergency
because it has to be and this is just
sheer contingency as to what you know
whether went in one condition or another
I mean so that's the s that's why the
only thing that scales
is an honest iterative self-critical pop
Aryan process of fighting toward you
know you fighting however dimly we can
see through the interface toward a
better explanation of drivers going or
having to see more clearly yeah and to
act on real implications yeah so I
really like this this last point of
yours about the durability of what
emerges here and in some sense I would
say we are in agreement that this is the
moment to address it because we don't
have the situation of the vaccine and
it's necessary for Public Health the
people who don't believe in it and get
it anyway well we do have one version of
that I mean this is why I'm often
accused of Islamophobia right I think
jihadism as a set of ideas just can't
the the gloves have to be off with
respect to how bad this set of ideas is
right so it's like do you have to
pretend to respect Islam as much as you
respect
Anglicanism or to be as patient with it
no you really don't because Islam is too
busy respecting jihadism right and so I
like it we have to ram this through
unapologetically right and this is where
and this politically this becomes
inconvenient and this is where you know
you get into circumstances where people
are criticism criticized in Islam for
the wrong reasons because they're
actually xenophobes and bigots and you
know neo-nazis and you want to have
nothing to do with those people but in a
space where no one left of center will
say an honest word about the differences
among religions you know this is this is
not the time to be mincing words with
what we know to be true jihadism is not
the same thing as any other strand of
mainstream religion now and it is it is
not the jihadists do not stand to to
Islam the way the Branch Davidians
stands stood to Christianity or the
Westboro Baptist Church stands to
Christianity I mean this is just that
these are false analogies it's a far
bigger problem as is Islamism you know
'men to in which mean with with which
jihadism is wrapped and so again this is
just a this is a place where I think we
have to I mean that I've always
acknowledged there's a role for
different voices here but I think we are
more in the position of you know we've
got a pandemic and unacknowledged
pandemic and we've got these people who
have a a taboo around even talking about
the utility of vaccination right and so
we have to we we have to have it we had
to do philosophy on a deadline here you
know this is I agree and I think it's an
important one I would only add that I
want to do that analysis when it comes
time to it in the proper geopolitical
context because although I find the
analysis compelling that there is
something especially frightening in
jihadist Islam there's also a context in
which it caught fire which I think we
have to be honest about but anyway
that's not no let's not go down that
we're going to our fourth hour what
we'll be going into our fourth hour on
tackle another topic that we can't do
that so Sam let me say this has been a
great pleasure and an honor and I should
say often I ask guests where they can
find you my listeners know exactly where
they can find you and I will say to them
that I signed up for your podcast this
morning and I suggest they do the same
it actually feels quite good to sign up
for your podcast it feels like a weight
off the shoulders and it's it's
something they should certainly consider
oh nice nice well let's see how you feel
when I start reading your mattress ads
after all right says it's been a
pleasure thanks so much
[Music]
[Applause]